all right welcome everybody we are
finally finally finally i am so glad to
say
on the fourth and final night
of the republican national convention we
will be hearing
from donald trump tonight who will
officially accept
the re-nomination uh to the
uh candidacy the republican candidacy
and
it it has been absolutely horrible and a
lot of you guys have written to me and
said
it's really bad like it's weaponized
and you're right and it's been horrible
and i'm really really glad that it's
ending tonight because it's just
it's been so bad and we we were talking
about it a little bit today on the bonus
show and how
it's sort of it's just the worst of
politics you can't even really fact
check the rnc because
it's all lies just one example
is this continued refrain that things
are out of control in this country
and thus you should vote for trump
because
somehow it's biden's fault i mean it's
crazy because the argument is
right now trump's president and the
streets are chaotic
so re-elect trump and i was actually
glad to see that joe biden made himself
the vice president echoed the president
last night by by telling
americans that they would not be safe in
joe biden's america
well you know look um if you think about
it donald trump saying
uh you're not gonna be safe in joe
biden's america all the video being
played is being played in donald trump's
america
exactly the point exactly the point it's
such a
simple point but an important one and
i'm glad to see
joe biden finally uh finally making it
um we are going to okay so
oliver wilde says that the recap is
night one was identity politics night
two was god knight three was the
military and tonight is a putin
appearance here's the way i see it
um night one was unhinged
upper night where like don jr seemed to
be on uppers
kimberly guilfoyle seemed to be on
uppers night two was
downer night where melania
was barely conscious during her speech
trump looked like he slept through it it
was just downer
down or night night three last night
was delusional night where just
the it was hard to find any truth being
told
you had to we looked under rocks we
looked everywhere we couldn't find
anything true being said last night
and also dangerous yesterday i think
that mike
mike pence's speech was dangerous in
ways that i explained today
uh in a youtube clip you can watch
already we'll see what tonight is i
don't want to get ahead of it i want to
actually see what it is before i uh
before i evaluate it
i did have a couple of other clips
donald trump it looked like he slept
through a briefing he couldn't really be
bothered
to uh where was this yeah check this out
government response uh when it comes to
uh this hurricane and
any other natural disaster that uh we
may see in the future
uh and next slide slide four please
so just a a taste of uh some of the
resources that we have
on the ground uh uh in response of uh
for this hurricane so
really engaged huh guys from fema staff
that are here
in this building uh that are embedded
with governors and their emergency
operations centers
uh in multiple states army corps of
engineers with their
power and roof teams that are on the
ground doing assessments uh
urban search and rescue teams as urban
social and rescue teams start from
indianapolis
uh indiana test force one is out could
he at least pretend to listen
they're today doing assessments uh
communications teams we have
mobile mercy uh response
units out there that give extra capacity
to
locals that anyway so there was trump
barely able to stay awake during a
coronavirus briefing
um by the way uh kamal harris gave a
speech
and just making making a lot of sense
the pandemic
it's relentless you can't stop it with a
tweet
you can't create a distraction and hope
it'll go away
it doesn't go away by its nature
a pandemic is unforgiving
if you get it wrong at the beginning the
consequences are catastrophic
yeah so anyway i'm looking forward to
seeing her debate mike pence
if and when that happens it is scheduled
but there are some who believe the
debates are for whatever reason not
going to happen
um so we i i believe that they will i
believe that they will
okay uh let's see if we can
what else do we need to kind of set up
for the evening we did have one
challenge here
oh rock croix asks if trump will achieve
peak plasma tonight via super chat i
certainly hope so um yesterday someone
dubbed me david plosman and i kind of
like it
um milo k yesterday issued a challenge
during the stream and we failed and milo
today is issuing another challenge
an easy and fair challenge milo wants to
see us at 971
000 subscribers on youtube by the end of
the stream let me see where we are right
now
we're almost at 970. you know that's
reasonable we're only 1500 from 971
we're 500 from 970
and another thousand from 971 so that
may actually be doable milo
um oh chakaseki says there's a coveted
party at the white house without masks
testing or distancing did demented donny
forget the pandemic yeah i just saw a
report
from yamiche alcindor pointing out that
there are no
um there are no tests for people
attending
and there are no masks for people
attending
thanks to the serfs tv for raiding with
350 people great to get things
kick-started i think we definitely need
that tonight because it is going to be a
brutal night
also brian rudolph is new member number
one on my website we have set the goal
of 59 tonight where did i get that
number
very simple that's the number we got to
last night
and so i figured we would just try to
best that so 59
um and then also by continued popular
demand we are keeping the number of
twitch subscribers up on the screen
that vertical blue rectangle above my
head
also is where your messages show up if
you include a message with your twitch
subscription we did climb to about 14
10 yesterday but you know these things
are constantly rolling over as many of
you can imagine
there's boy meets mini cheering 59 bits
i guess in celebration of targeting 59
members so a lot of exciting things
going on
sunil wani says trump always touts low
black unemployment what specifically has
he done
exactly or is it safe to say we'd have
the same level under clinton yep it's
relatively safe to say that
um he he often touts it but when
unemployment is low it
tends to be low for most groups um and
uh that that is exactly you're now
thinking
uh sunil i like that chris
schaeler says how are people on the
right defending written house
uh i don't know how they're doing i
don't know why they're doing it
but the way but how they're doing it is
very very
flaccidly just you know tucker carlson
saying i can understand why
thanks to freedom jesus for gifting 10
subscriptions over on twitch
as well as petrified 82 for subscribing
with twitch prime putting us at the
perfectly round number
of 1400. courtney pollock says hatch act
i just can't anymore yep there's no
there's not going to be any
repercussions
for violating the hatch act it is uh the
possible repercussions are removal
in november via the electoral process
i know some people get mad when i say
that and they say no but david
they are violating the hatch act they
should be held accountable i'm with you
i'm with you it's just not going to
happen and so voting is the way
that is the uh that is the path forward
oh i did want to see who else was on the
schedule today
scheduled day four i mean we we know
that trump of course
but uh let's take a look at a new york
times
article about what is on the calendar
for tonight
um okay who's speaking tonight stacia
breitman i don't know who that is ben
carson
he'll have trouble staying awake i'm
sure uh senator tom cotton
horrible bomb thrower and dorn debbie
flood
rudy giuliani will be speaking that
should be interesting
the reverend franklin graham will be
speaking that's horrible
alice johnson patrick lynch wade
mayfield kevin mccarthy and mitch
mcconnell
wow uh dan scavino is horrifying
ivanka dana white the president of
ultimate fighting that could that
possibly be for real that's insane
uh dana white will be speaking and then
yes we will also be hearing from
donald trump this evening looks like the
convention is
about to start with some of this
propaganda video
let's see i want to get a backup stream
as well
backup streams are really important here
they've not yet gone to it but it looks
like they will soon there's trump
pretending to understand sports
other super chats continue to come in um
you can get your message up on the
screen if you're watching on youtube
by using super chat that'll show up in
the lower left
and with twitch it'll show up above my
head like for example parker moe's
just sent the message via twitch another
month another prime sub you've stolen
from steven destiny
bonnell ii very very exciting
super guy says the only way to hold
trump accountable is to vote i agree
bolo turner says congrats on 15 years
david i appreciate your insight even
when i don't completely agree with it
the work you do is essential and
necessary in these dark times here's to
another 15 years
our gonzales says how do you effectively
combat an opponent the republican party
when they're willing
to throw out the rules and do anything
they can be it legal or not to put their
fingers on the scale
i addressed this in a couple of recent
youtube clips where i actually make it
very clear
we should not stoop to their level um
and that when we do it might seem like
we're winning but really we're not when
we do that
we have some early members who i want to
thank so i don't fall behind
zach davis's new member number two
stephen werner is new member number
three
and roland wohlmann is new member number
four today
very much appreciate that we had a
beautiful day yesterday with 59
and we are going to look to tie that
today let's see if we have another feed
we do okay so pbs is now going to be
picking up
the republican convention feed as
if you're just joining me i i mentioned
at the top of the feed i am
so glad so glad that this is the last
night because this has been
truly dystopian and horrible so we'll
all deal with it together
and then it'll be over we will go uh oh
i'm not going to do franklin graham
again i've been skipping all of the
religious components not because i am
uh angry with people who are religious
but merely because i think there should
be separation of church and state
and therefore i don't really have any
need or desire to publicize
prayer at the start of a republican
convention
astrolycos says hey david long time
subscriber and new member here how much
time do you think kyle rittenhouse will
serve in prison
i have no idea i mean i don't know how
they're going to be charging him it
seems they're charging him as an adult
but
anything could be negotiated uh so i
have no idea
i have no idea owen carpenter says why
do you subject yourself to this nonsense
i could ask you the same question owen
but somehow we both ended up here
tonight
let's uh let's make the best of it
if we can and it is a tough thing
it is a tough thing to do for sure
incomplete joker says start my new job
tomorrow after losing my
old to furlough so i can't get a
headache from watching all the lies
we'll catch up with your show thank you
david appreciate it
thank you jeremy landry says how anyone
sees sanity in the republican national
convention
hurts my soul i'm with you
i'm with you very very much thanks to
marty mazz for subscribing with
twitch prime um
it does seem as though that twitch
subscriber number is
usually delayed by about 30 seconds i
don't totally know why but it seems that
way
andrew dobson says given trump's poor
social distancing in age what would
happen to his poll numbers if donald
trump caught covid
and was put on a ventilator for weeks
that's a question i don't have an answer
to
he could shoot people on fifth avenue
and
uh not lose support but could he get
coveted and be put on a ventilator for
three weeks and not lose support
that i don't know uh now moving into the
pledge of allegiance
with military children doing the pledge
of allegiance
um let's see uh oh there are no
closed captions here oh okay so there
are cl what's
why aren't they uh this is weird it
doesn't seem like they have the
oh hold on here's the direct feed okay
beautiful okay now we're now we're in
business and we have closed captioning
going
let's hear from kevin mccarthy first
main main speaker of the evening
our ancestors braved the unknown they
built this nation oh
actually it's just part of a propaganda
montage so we're not going to do that
we're not going to do it
we do have 40 seconds left to get to
level 5
on a twitch hype train which is exciting
jr says every oh god you proclaim
every can you imagine you ask every time
you put your hands on your head and look
appalled into your camera
gets me to laughing each time i am
grateful
all right i appreciate the message let's
see if now it's the the full speech
we will do it again we confronted china
head on
tore up bad trade deals and made better
ones yeah still propaganda so we're
still uh still not in there
um joey ruggiero says what do you think
joe rogan thinks about dana white
speaking tonight
i have no idea whatsoever lumber
lumbermix says hey david
love your only fans keep it up of course
i don't
have an only fans but i do have
a cameo no only fans i do have a cameo
let's let's keep that straight my
friends desiree dewitt says david the
one dim
highlight of this convention crap fest
was you reading my super chat on night
one
everyone super chat and join all right
thank you desiree i appreciate that
uh hella cool guy says making fun of
republicans is literally ableism
that's aggressive that's very very
aggressive
laura malcolm says
orange is a lemon they are trying to
sell to their shrinking base i think i
understand that
trump is a lemon ryan lafleur says hey
david would appreciate
a quick shout out for my girlfriend and
nude listener
cat lee thanks cat welcome it's so great
to have you here
i hope that ryan is whispering sweet
nothings
about the rnc into your ear tonight as
we all watch together
maestro cam says what's your favorite
music to drum to
oh i couldn't possibly narrow that down
uh there's just so much but i've been uh
i've been drumming to a lot of jazz
lately
some cool jazz i would say not music but
just
cool jazz um robert zimmer says that the
kenosha shooter will get
10 to 40 years for felony murder
10 seems low i'm not going to lie i'm
not going to lie
cejasuke has subscribed on twitch and
says
david only fans when never
never no only fans just cameo
i call it cameo but i guess it's
pronounced cameo i don't know
that's what the kids are telling me
these days uh people asking if the 15th
anniversary coupon code is still working
it is i'm not i'm not actively promoting
it but
we have a secret coupon code that's even
better than 2020 now on my website which
is
15 year one five year and uh
that's an even bigger discount and it
does still work it does still work
semi truck driver says what were your
thoughts on trump before he became
president even before the birth or
nonsense
kind of like watching the apprentice i
didn't think too much of them before
then let's see what's up with this first
speech
20 years ago i moved to washington dc
to attend howard university
i was at a crossroads just like america
is today
i grew up on strand hill road in
cleveland
a blue-collar street in a blue-collar
city
when the media talks about forgotten
places
or working class people who are
overlooked
and struggling hard there's usually some
stock photo
of people who don't look like me
they never seem to show people like my
mom
who worked two jobs as a gas station
clerk
and a mom she showed me how to persevere
they never seem to show people like my
dad who plowed plowed snow
in the winter and paved streets in the
summer
who stood by me through thick and thin
and taught me strong
values every day
they never seemed to show people like me
at first i didn't live the values my
parents taught me
i won a starting spot on the varsity
football team
but i only had a 1.9 gpa
but then i broke my leg
it took a broken leg for me to really
get moving in life
i prioritized schoolwork went to howard
and ended up working for the president
of the united states
growing up i never really known a
republican
i believed all the stereotypes
it took a meeting republicans who shared
my values to show me
i was wrong donald trump knows
that in the work of revitalizing
communities
america's strength is america's people
and i can tell you he really cares
about what and he takes action
every issue important to black
communities
has been a priority for him prison
reform
rebuilding broken families bringing jobs
back
to america jobs in cleveland
jobs in detroit jobs in milwaukee
president trump knows that education
is the great equalizer that's why he's
secured
yeah people pointing out that this is an
anecdotal story of sort of
limited policy value you guys are
completely right
for school choice in the wake
of the murder of ahmad aubry
george floyd and legend tala pharaoh
a moment of national racial
consciousness i have seen
his true conscience i just wish everyone
could see the deep empathy he shows to
families
whose loved ones were killed in
senseless violence
president trump has made it clear that
if you want
safe communities you must have police
departments
with the highest standards
right i'll never forget strand hill road
or the people of cleveland they're tough
smart and tell it like it is
that's president trump for a new yorker
he's got a lot of cleveland heart and
i'm proud to say
that he's my president god bless america
i don't know about you guys but i got
rnc bingo i filled my board just with
this first speech so i'm basically done
with bingo for the night not sure about
you guys
um boy meets minnie has gifted five
subscriptions on twitch which i really
do appreciate that's that's a beautiful
beautiful thing
um we do have continued activity
happening in a lot of different places
jillian foye
is new member number five today at
joinedpakman.com jillian
thank you my god you're doing a lot
tonight for us jillian i really
appreciate it
welcome to the uh 7 300 of you that are
watching
on youtube as well as the 1400 watching
on twitch it's great to have you all
here
we are building up to uh donald trump
accepting the nomination scheduled to be
around 10 30 p.m eastern time so we do
have some time
um super chats are a great way to get in
touch with me
a lot of people demand continuing to
demand i think it's called only fans not
just fans unless just fans is another
thing
kyle hopper says i think it's trump's a
teddy bear
knight david plosman
master 101 says match gripper
traditional grip for drumming i always
learn match script and i actually i play
open-handed on a right-handed kid i'm
lefty as many of you know
left-handed and um i the way i learned
was open-handed
uh sort of a hybrid grip although
sometimes i will go over to more of a
french grip
on a right-handed kit so i'm playing the
kick drum with the right foot
but still playing my hi-hat with the
with the left hand it really works for
me and i later found out actually
that the great dom famularo
um well into his drumming career like i
think in the last maybe 15 years ago you
know as
an adult um switched to
open handed even though i think he's not
a lefty
just to get a different look at the kit
and it's worked pretty well with him
for him it's worked pretty well
astralico says i love identity politics
and virtue signaling now republicans
also i love your secret only fans for
super members oh don't mention that
i'm supposed to act like i don't have an
only fans please
chaka seki says have you heard the new q
anon conspiracy about donald trump's
waistline it's called
girtherism i like that i have not heard
that
q is actually becoming such a big thing
that it's i'm we're
potentially going to interview someone
who's an expert on it
um
yes people now are confused i really am
left-handed that wasn't a joke i don't
know what kind of a joke that would be
see i'm
manipulating the mouse with my left hand
here
what else do we have sim king says
would you create an only fan's account
to debate ben shapiro on only fans
about how ethical or unethical sex
workers are no i have no reason to
create an only fans thank you
the dingle dong for life says how much
diaper pudding
will trump be packing tonight well said
uh connor brenner says david do you
think any of these speakers think about
their place in history how
they'll be viewed i think they do and
they think that it'll be really great
for their career
i suppose most will be such a small
footnote in history that nobody will
remember them anyway yeah i think
they're thinking more in the immediate
it's good for them to be
speaking at the rnc all right here
is jeff van som jeff
van drew okay i speak to you as a member
of the republican party
but it always wasn't that way how i
became a republican
says a lot about today's democratic
party
i'm from south jersey where we work hard
look after our neighbors and care about
our communities
years ago i was a local dentist and was
asked by the democrats to run for a town
council seat
i had my doubts and i explained that my
views were
middle of the road to conservative but
the local leaders said the democratic
party was a
big tent and that they accepted people
like me
i was elected to council as a democrat
but as i won seats for county office
state legislature
and then congress i noticed things were
changing
the democratic party had become less
accepting of american tradition
less believing in american
exceptionalism less supportive of
traditional
faith and family this was not the party
that i knew guys sorry to interrupt but
something really funny is going on
um i just got a message forwarded from
from staff
saying that someone is emailing in
saying my stream has no
audio and it's like obviously it does
because i've been streaming for a half
hour and people are reacting to what i'm
saying like
sometimes when these uh like tech errors
happen
and someone thinks i've been i've just
been streaming for a half hour nobody
can hear me
the chat is all talking to each other
it's it's like weird you know
and usually it's like oh your device is
muted or something mixes
now they were four open borders against
our police
and against our god-given rights
when the radical democrats went after
president trump with impeachment
they made another mistake democratic
leaders told me
that i had to vote for impeachment or my
life would be made difficult
and i wouldn't be allowed to run again
listen
i'm from south jersey and you better
come at me
with more than just loud words and empty
threats
okay i've voted no on impeachment and it
was an easy call
right i met with president trump
and he made me feel more comfortable and
welcome
in the oval office than nancy pelosi
ever made me feel in her caucus and a
few days later
i officially changed parties and i
became a republican
let me tell you about joe biden when the
democrats tried to order me around
i was ready willing and able to say
i've had enough with their radical
socialist
agenda there's no socialists
there's no democrat there's no
socialists in the senate
and even the ones who use that term in
the house or
i would argue aren't even really
socialists maybe maybe a couple
being told what to do by the radicals
running my former party
the same radicals trying to install him
as their puppet president
when i'm at my local diner i tell people
that america is the best
nation in the world yeah and he wonders
why his food tastes terrible
get that way republicans independents
and even democrats they all know that in
president trump's america
we have a strong military strong support
for our police
strong support i love this super chat
diamond joe
hey david street has no audio
or video i've been streaming a black
screen and people are just interacting
like there's actually a program going on
affect our environment there are a lot
of democrats
who support our president and are
disgusted
for what their old party what my old
party
has become here's my advice
be true to who you are now
not who the democrats used to be that's
why i'm a proud republican
and why i will be voting for donald
trump
thank you and may god bless you god
bless our president
is that closing about god bless a
requirement do you guys know like are
you
are these speakers contractually
obligated to do it
for me the most important issue okay so
uh
people getting very very hyped up about
that but really just a pretty standard
uh uh
speech you know trying to create the
idea that a whole bunch of people are
abandoning the democratic party or what
whatever
and certainly that that is not true um
oliver wilde says
david plosman is great but how do you
feel about pac addicts as a term for
your fans
i would not i don't think it's
appropriate for me to really be involved
in that
decision that's more for others to
decide jeff says really scared by how
many people i know are buying into some
of this by the way
love the only fans yeah my secret only
fans you should see
i i'm i actually so bella thorne made
two million on only fans
i made 2.1 it's but it's completely
secret it's a secret only fans it's
unbelievable
aldo parenti says hello david pardon me
if you've already discussed this how
proper
but what are your thoughts on the
movement for a people's party and will
you be covering the convention for it
next week thanks
i don't really have thoughts on it and
i'm not going to be covering the
convention next week i apologize i can't
i can't cover everything and i've gotten
enough enough conventions under my belt
for probably
several years uh my mythos mint
says your camera has been upside down
this entire time
yeah pm fant wait pian
fart okay i got that one totally wrong
pianfart
says i thought republicans were all
about facts over feelings but most of
the rnc
speakers are all personal anecdotes
that's all they are yeah
kenny kiddich says there's a technical
issue the rnc has no integrity please
fix yeah that's not something i can fix
with my computer
d smith says david i soiled by myself
okay that sounds like a problem i can't
really help with
story guy asks whether i believe trump
will accept defeat
i think he will eventually accept defeat
not
in the immediate
david gora says i guess separation of
church and state is no longer a thing
correct
not for these clowns peter stewart says
david i enjoy your show but find some of
your cultural critiques expel
especially on religion to be misinformed
would you consider having more religious
thinkers from the left on your show
thanks maybe you know the thing is
there's not a big clamoring
for that from my audience when i've done
that in the past
it no barely anybody watches it people
aren't super interested in that and i do
have to balance what what the audience
is interested in
and to be perfectly frank you know um
what exactly is it
it sounds like you disagree with me but
to say i'm disinformed you've got to
make that case what
what did i get wrong rather than what do
you disagree with me about those are two
different things
lexi yates says when you mute the
convention
it makes the fact where did that go
hold on it makes the fact that there's
no audio or video even worse exactly
james montalbano says david the stream
has no video audio
time or space am suspended motionless in
a white void
very good marlena harris couldn't
request an absentee ballot from
louisiana to vote in the presidential
election i'm in college in ohio even
though last year i had been able to
request one i'm a bit concerned well
when you say you weren't able to
does that was there a technical error
did someone tell you you can't get one
uh let's see more lou says hey mate do
you consider yourself quite
partisan well i'm not a democrat or a
republican
i'm i think in massachusetts it's called
unregistered
but i am certainly on the left and this
is a left-wing show for sure
thanks to neptune5 for subscribing
on twitch you are subscriber 1415
today at joinpackman.com before we get
to the next speaker let me just do a
couple other new member thank yous
because we have a big goal tonight
thomas satco is new member number six
holly doyle is number seven
terry o'sullivan is eight wayne smith is
number nine
and bj mackey is number 10
tonya bot is number 11.
as we get to uh let's see who this is
and listen in
but a golf course oh my god
one day i was cleaning golf clubs when a
man pulled into the parking lot
yeah there wasn't a single person who
didn't know who it was
everyone's jaws were on the ground it
was donald trump
all i could think was nobody will ever
believe this at school tomorrow by the
way people saying in the chat i used to
call myself a social democrat and now i
don't no no you guys are confused
i've always called myself a social
democrat i never called myself a
democratic socialist nothing's changed
nothing's changed everybody relax every
day when i consider the
journey we have taken together and taken
with so many of you watching tonight
because my personal story with donald
trump well something's up with this
guy's eyes
is yours too he saw potential in me
a spark the possibility that i could be
more
do more and achieve more than even i
thought was possible this guy's scaring
me
that's how he views this country too we
have all just scratched the surface
of what we can do together
if there's one thing i hope you will
hear from me tonight it is this
president trump is a kind and decent man
i wish you could be at his side with me
to see his endless kindness
to everyone he meets seems sincere
the media could be a fog machine
creating a partisan mist around
everything
that's hard to see through but in 2016
you navigated through it all you found
your way through the swamp
and you arrived safely on the other side
with donald j
trump as your new president
there are some things that were true
then reasons why you choose
him as your country's leader that remain
true
today anybody understand the case this
guy's making i don't know if he wants me
to vote for trump or against him
american people must know their
president isn't building his life
he's building yours he knows the
president
cannot be bullied president trump is the
first leader
who's been too strong too tough
and too savvy to be crushed by the
status quo
establishment he's too good in the
political media class
you know the president cannot be beaten
he's got a fighting spirit
like so many of you do and winning for
america
is what he does while they call it chaos
president trump calls it change
just think about what we achieve
together with president trump
the strongest economy in history
the lowest unemployment rate for almost
all demographic groups
black americans hispanic americans
women and so many more
he did that once and he will do it again
you know it and i know it
we all just need somebody to believe in
our capacity to do great things
donald trump believed in me when i was a
teenage golf caddy
and he was already one of the wealthiest
most famous people
on the entire planet he saw my potential
even when i couldn't he sees greatness
in our country too
and in each of you he believes the world
this guy actually seems traumatized and
i don't say that as a joke
uh he he seems like a traumatized
individual
just think about what he has done with
this convention
you've heard from real americans with
real stories
people who are just like us
people whose lives have been forever
impacted by the president
and his policies you've heard from
people like john peterson
who has a factory in ohio tanya
weinreice
who has a small business in montana
jason joyce
a fisherman from maine and chris
peterson
a dairy farmer from wisconsin
you've seen a man who turned his life
around get a second chance with a
presidential pardon
you've seen brand new americans become
our fellow citizens
in a ceremony at the white house
you felt the passion of pro-life and
religious freedom advocates
and listen to the heartfelt words of a
man whose family fled communism
and oppression who needs a non-stop
parade of politicians
when you've got an army of the people
behind you on november 3rd
vote for the man who believes in america
and believes in
you i know which one that is vote for my
friend
your friend wait our friend
uh-oh donald j trump
thank you and god bless the united
states of america
wow bizarre speech i don't know what was
crazier the content or the delivery one
really trying to one-up it here's mitch
mcconnell before you denied from the
commonwealth of kentucky
as the only leader in washington not
from either new york or
is this live obviously not stability
look out for middle america
this election is incredibly
consequential for middle america
president trump knows he inherited the
first
generation of americans who couldn't
promise their children
a better life than their own he's made
it his
mission of this administration to change
that
i know because i work beside him every
day
today's democrat party doesn't want to
improve life for middle america
they prefer that all of us in flyover
country keep quiet
and let them decide how we should live
our lives
they want to tell you when you can go to
work
when your kids can go to school they
want to tax your job out of existence
isn't mitch the worst for unemployment
they want to tell you what kind of
car you can drive what sources of
information
are credible and even how many
hamburgers
you can eat there's that insane talking
point
biden will get rid of cows amendment
rights
they want free health care for illegal
immigrants yet they offer no protection
at all for unborn americans they want to
pack the supreme court with liberals
intent on eroding our constitutional
rights
and they want to codify all this by
making the swamp itself
washington d.c america's 51st state
with two more liberal senators we cannot
undo the damage that sounds pretty good
now you understand why democrats spent
an entire week telling us about who joe
biden
is not what he intends to do i'm
immensely proud of the work the
republican senate has done
we are the firewall against nancy
pelosi's agenda
like president trump we won't be bullied
by a liberal media intent on destroying
america's
institutions we will stand our post
on behalf of the millions of americans
whose stories
aren't told in today's newspapers whose
struggles
are just as real we'll continue to
support american families as we defeat
the coronavirus
and return our economy to the envy of
the world hopefully with a different
president right
which is why i'm asking you to support
republican senate candidates across the
country
and re-elect my friend president donald
trump
[Music]
okay so there's mitch mcconnell we heard
from dan scavino really getting through
a number of the speakers and then
ultimately building to the crescendo the
climax
uh of donald trump's speech gotti shock
says david i like sinking your stream in
hassan pikers and hearing both of you
comment at once what's your opinion on
hassan hassan's a friend of mine at
least as far as i know i don't think
we've had a falling out i know he and
stephen kenneth destiny bennell ii have
had a falling out but
i went out to dinner with hassan last
time i was in la but i don't really
watch
his stream so i don't i don't really
know what he says i think that he
is he a socialist does he want the
takeover of the means of production does
he want a social i'm just not exactly
sure
on that but um you know it
uh we've always had a perfectly
reasonable
uh uh friendship todd the magnificent
twitch
altruist dan has subscribed walk like a
ghost has subscribed i appreciate that
um a couple other people to thank i want
to stay on top of this
tim r bider is new member number 12
today
freddie erazo is new member number 13.
cena zahadpur is number 14
joseph mclaughlin is number 15 and conor
ashfield
is new member number 16 today where did
we get a goal of 59
perfectly simple we got to 59 yesterday
here's dana white this is insane
if you know who i am what i do and that
i am friends with the president
i spoke at this convention four years
ago and i'm back because i believe
we need president trump's leadership why
is he yelling
before the pandemic president trump
built the greatest economy
in our nation's history and created
opportunities
for all americans like no one before him
to do well financial markets hit
all-time highs
unemployment was at an all-time low and
we weren't facing the lawless
destruction
that now is occurring in a few of our
great cities
it blows my mind how quickly some of the
leadership in this country
has forgotten the critical role first
responders play
in our society nobody police departments
and other law enforcement
even some fire departments have faced
opposition from many in this country
but they are always the people who are
asked to step
up when things are at their worst and
put themselves at risk
that has certainly been the case during
this ongoing pandemic
come on america defunding these vital
positions
is not the answer remember biden doesn't
want to defund the police so it's really
a non-starter
care of us and now more than ever we
need to take care of them
now let's talk about covid and let's be
very honest about it
no one person and no one place could
have anticipated the challenges
that covet would bring and yet we did
worse than just about every country
all these obstacles head on he
immediately put protective measures in
place
and he reached out to the best and the
brightest leading american businesses
across all industries to discuss what he
and his administration could do
to get the economy back up and running
safely
let me give you more detail in early
april president trump organized a task
force
of business leaders across the country
and i was fortunate enough to serve on
that task force
firsthand i had the opportunity to
witness how hard it was isn't that the
task force that just got all sorts of
different wrestling and martial arts
opened back up in the state of florida
with ron desantis help
i personally observed his ability to
listen
and understand the issues impacting
americans of all backgrounds
it was clear his highest priority
was always the health and safety of
everyone
in our country not just republicans not
just supporters
but every single american they
literally had a plan thanks to kushner
to not do much early because it looked
like it was mostly going to affect blue
states the truth is the opposite of what
dana white is saying
all sports leagues involved figure out a
way
to overcome the challenges of staging
live professional sporting events
in the middle of a pandemic and you know
what
we did it the ufc was the first to do it
and we are continuing to do it now other
sports
have joined us and some of the lessons
learned
are being used to help reopen other
types of businesses
and schools
make no mistake about it we still have a
long way to go
and that is why we need a leader with
president trump's
unique attributes at this critical time
i have said it before
and i will say it again he is one of the
most loyal human beings
i have ever met the man has unstoppable
energy
no one and i mean no one is going to
outwork this guy
but most importantly he truly loves and
believes in our country
he believes in the people of this
country
america is a place everyone wants a
solid job
they want to take care of their family
they want to support the community
assist the less fortunate and enjoy the
freedom
this country has provided to all of us
while we have certainly experienced a
ton of negativity in 2020
president trump's mindset is to work
tirelessly
to find solutions to problems and help
restore
america he did it once and i'm telling
you right now
he will do it again and remember
president trump
may be the only president in modern
times who has actually done
everything he said he would do during
his campaign
there's this quote okay uh replace
obamacare with something beautiful
build the wall fix trade
i'm having trouble understanding that
one let us have at it
and what that means to me is as
americans
we work hard to overcome adversity and
we face the tough times head on
irrespective of your gender race
religion
or sexual orientation what unites us
as a nation is freedom equality
and opportunity that's what it means to
be an american
ladies and gentlemen let's reelect
president trump
let's figure out what the problems are
and continue to find solutions to those
problems
then let's get to work i'd like to close
with this please while it's critically
important to re-elect president trump
this pandemic has also taught us to be
very
very careful who you select as your next
governor
senator congress person and mayor
it is so important to vote and don't
think that your vote doesn't matter
because to be honest with you it has
never mattered more
than it does right now true thank you
and have a great evening america
well that is really powerful powerful
lunacy
here is uh who's this
aloha and good evening i'm utah attorney
general sean reyes
okay so this one we're going to go um
we're going to do a little mute skis on
this one
um i want to hear from you guys and see
what's on people's minds
t-stan says via twitch subscription
simply yikes
beautifully uh concise and succinct
uh summary of what we've been hearing so
far
um tom miller says thanks for this covet
update dr ufc
[Laughter]
rocco thompson says hassan and david the
dreamiest leftists in the biz
the people demand a joint only fans now
there were a couple other things i
wanted to get to dan of earth asks if
i'm covering the people's party
convention on the 30th
i'm not i'm taking the weekend off i
have a pog champs match on saturday but
other than that i'm taking the weekend
off two weeks of
conventions in a row uh i'm going to be
i'm going to be off for the weekend
very very powerfully and then probably
broadcasting from the bunker on monday
we're going to be doing a bunker bunker
duty
tom owain says hassan called you david
paklib is that bad
i don't even i don't even get the insult
tim
arb oh wait no braden braden wilmer says
david can you shout out your boys braden
and dan in pittsburgh p.s
stopped talking about the secret only
fans yes pittsburgh
where uh i am very much acquainted with
the
driving maneuver a pittsburgh left a
pittsburgh left i drive around boston
and uh whenever i do certain things on
the road
and my girlfriend doesn't like it i say
it's just a pittsburgh left don't worry
in pittsburgh i'd be i'd be ridiculed
for not doing what i just did and then
she seems to it seems to be an
acceptable explanation
um what else do we have here oliver
wilde says trump would have to
acknowledge problems as such and not as
hoaxes to be even to even be evaluated
on his response times
ryan fulton says although i'm in the uk
i spent years in southern arizona and
there was already a wall for a lot of
the border
yeah there is fencing but remember
that's not what trump
wants caleb ehaya says dana white just
doesn't want to pay his fighters a fair
wage so trump is helpful for that
i don't know enough about that to be
perfectly frank
uh if you're just joining us as we get
close to 9 15 pm eastern time on the
fourth of
four days the final day finally we made
it of the republican national convention
uh we are waiting for donald trump
scheduled to speak in about
75 minutes um
we i want to welcome all 10 000 of you
who are currently watching on youtube
and also the roughly 2 000 people that
are watching on twitch it's great to
have everybody here
um what else do we have zachary ezioni
says what did trump have to do with the
israel peace deal
remember there is there is no israel
peace deal
in terms of the israeli-palestinian
conflict relationship
uh the diplomatic relations have been
normalized between
the uae and israel and a lot of people
confused by that elegant elliot
often says you're a beef stew gangsta
talk for a chump ha ha
yeah you know the other day when
somebody asked me my favorite whack
packers from the howard stern show
and i said eric the actor beetlejuice
and
the new bigfoot elegant elliot actually
is is maybe my earliest favorite whack
packer it's just
unbelievable absolutely unbelievable
um donna williams says why do they
repeatedly show the statue of liberty
when they despise what it stands for
thank you for all you do
it's all propaganda ross pagarian says
don't forget about rudy and ben who are
coming soon yeah we're scheduled to hear
from
ben carson and rudy giuliani
giuliani uh and i think giuliani is
going to be unhinged
i'm really curious a couple months ago
rudy giuliani reappeared on tv
where half of his head was shaved and
his glasses
were crooked and i think you can
actually find my youtube clip
i think it's called half shaved giuliani
it was one of the weirdest hairstyles i
had ever seen and giuliani
what was coming out of his mouth made
about as much sense as his half-shaved
head did it was really really strange
do we want to hear from debbie flood
let's see foundry and machine shop in
wisconsin that manufactures cast bronze
architectural hardware
okay my father who was a world war ii
veteran
started the business with some used
equipment and the american dream
today we are one of the only u.s
companies left who make our products
from start to finish
under one roof we really make things
and we love it when we lost nearly 50
percent of our business to china in the
mid 2000s
we wondered how a small company like
ours could continue to compete
at that time joe biden was a senator he
voted to normalize trade with
china and help pave the way for them to
join the wto
even though they were hurting american
companies like ours
but we're tenacious and we're creative
here it is
we took a risk and purchased a 3d
printer
3d printing technology allows us to do
things that you know where this is
now we can take a customer's id from
staircase
to sample to production in just a few
weeks
this opened up new opportunities for us
later we fought our way through the
great recession
then donald trump was elected and we
breathed a sigh of relief
he actually fought for american workers
and american craftsmen
he actually cared about bringing back
those three beautiful words
made in america we no longer had to
succeed
despite government now the government
was on our side
we enjoyed a thriving economy stimulated
by president trump's pro-business
and pro-worker policies thanks to the
trump tax cuts
i've been able to raise my employees
wages
i don't even think she believes what
she's saying so we're going to mute a
little bit of this
uh thomas neil is complaining that i
missed
your other two super chats i i apologize
i mean listen i can't
i'm doing the best i can okay here's one
thomas neil says
hey it's the bong dude again do you
agree that's about to take a position of
power from police to president should
undergo thorough mental screening
do you agree that's about oh my god
um power from police to president i
don't know if you're saying police
should have a mental screening or
presidents should but both should
and then thomas neil said that dude is
coked up lmao all right thank you
uh thomas i uh did not mean to miss your
super chats but we did get to them
foo's coach says wasn't rudy giuliani a
somewhat respectable guy during 9 11.
now he's the evil super troll he was
certainly more respected then
more respected thanks to pico de gallo
and i'm i'm not pronouncing that
incorrectly that is how it that that's
actually
the username for subscribing with twitch
thanks to short brief and my cool
also for subscribing uh we are right now
by the way
1422 twitch subscribers is the most
we've ever had
sorry i glitched there yeah it's the
most we've ever had
um caleb i i coming in with a 100
new zealand is it dollars 100 new
zealand dollar super chat
david you're doing a great thing with
your show so here to support you as a
kiwi
it's shocking how american politics is
so dishonest
and partisan glad people like you are
here to educate dum-dums like me
on how to argue with progressive
for progressive policy i appreciate that
caleb thank you
thank you so much um
chris says watching from the uk 2am
after a late shift at work
this convention has been hilarious and
ridiculous
good job suffering through it for us it
has been
a lot of suffering it's been brutal
brutal brutal brutal
uh but we just have trump to go and then
we're gonna be out
and i think that that's a really great
thing
a really great thing because i really
can't take too much more of it
uh in any case what i was pulling up
before for you guys was
this video where uh again the title i
just love the title
half shaved giuliani goes crazy on fox
and as you can see uh rudy giuliani
showed up
with um no hair on half of his head
and i don't know exactly how it happened
but it was a really
what he said didn't make any more sense
than his haircut and that was a really
so anyway the reason it's relevant is
we're expecting to hear from rudy
giuliani tonight
and i look forward to it to be perfectly
honest with you
um thomas neil says no worries man keep
it up take my last two dollars
no i don't want anybody's last two
dollars unless you mean
just like the last two dollars you're
gonna super chat as i've said many times
before the show is for everybody i don't
want anybody's last two dollars but i
appreciate folks who send in messages
and support junior balogan says still
waiting on that health care plan trump
promised
he always says it'll arrive in a couple
of weeks the mixture of short memory
along with our toxic two-party system
really is a problem for our country
yeah i don't know if you guys remember
but when donald trump had that bizarre
interview with chris wallace on fox news
i guess it's been about six weeks um he
said that within two weeks we would have
a brand new health care plan signed into
law to replace obamacare
then he said it would be in place by the
end of august and
it just hasn't happened we which
i mean i just it was never happening
obviously but
um cl says as they speak about
nationalism can be can we be reminded
where ivanka's fashion line was
manufactured yeah china i believe
china as trump says d campbell says my
daughter is dual citizen
and is eligible to vote for the first
but border is closed
only open for essential service is
voting and essential service
you know i i don't fully understand
exactly the situation you're describing
but
can she vote absentee that's that's the
way i would probably look at it
tim r bider says shucks my bigger super
chat got
missed wanted to express my gratitude i
could have sworn i read it
tim r biter let's see
oh here it is super impressed that you
got my last name right i started out as
a christian conservative and traded that
in for secular humanism
your content was instrumental in
shifting me away from
selfish right libertarian mentality
beautiful tim very glad to hear that
very glad to hear that
peter stewart says given how insane 2020
has been what do you think the october
surprise will be
more insane than access hollywood i
imagine thanks david well remember when
we say october surprise we don't mean
something
bad for trump we mean something good and
i think it's going to be an announcement
that there's a vaccine
that's been approved even though it
won't be available in the immediate to
most people
and even though it won't have a thing to
do with donald trump i believe the
october surprise will be trump saying
we got it we got the vaccine
um gaudy shock says david i've watched
you plenty and
am not on my last dollar i'll give back
willingly great job thank you i
appreciate that
freakadelic is submitting a complaint
that i missed
the first super chat okay let's uh see
if trump loses can he really retain
power
just by being physically present in the
oval office
no on january 20th if trump loses he no
longer is the president of the united
states
okay that's it um
sharon ma okay uh you almost got me
you almost got me there what's your hair
routine i'm guessing you dampen it apply
prop
apply pomade style it and then finish
with a blow dry it looks professionally
done
no no no it's just i shower
i dry it a little bit i put in a product
called american
crew fiber and then i just let it dry
that's it
i don't do it's not anywhere near as
complex as you're making it out to be
darren dunn says trump cares so much
about americans that he packs in 1500 of
them tonight to get his narcissistic
supply
yeah if you're just joining us um there
are reportedly no covid tests for the
audience for trump's speech tonight as
well as no masks
so it could become quite a super
spreader event
phoenix is complaining that i missed
super chat
two nights in a row okay let's see if i
can find it
phoenix let's see here whoa things going
very much wrong here
phoenix phoenix says vote vote vote
if you don't vote trump wins this
november is your opportunity to tell
trump
that he is not the right potus for the
us
very much well said very much well said
all right we are about to go to the next
speaker so let me get caught up on thank
yous before we do
um amanda huggin kiss also known as
anita wood is new member number 17
today matthew deluca is new member
number 18.
jose gomez is number 19.
jose gomez also doubling up on patreon
making him
number 19 and 20. and then ray ludington
is number 21. thank you i really do
appreciate the the support the streams
have been brutally bad
but i really appreciate the generosity
with which
people have been uh supporting the
stream let's listen in just a little bit
here
and then we're going to be moving on to
subsequent speeches back to me
he was murdered by people who didn't
know and just didn't care
he would have done anything to help them
[Music]
violence and destruction are not
legitimate forms of protest
they do not safeguard black lives they
only destroy them
president trump understands this has
offered federal help to restore order in
our communities
offered in a time when police
departments are short on resources
and manpower we need that help
we should accept that help we must heal
before we can affect change
but we cannot heal amid devastation and
chaos
[Music]
president trump knows we need more
davids in our communities
i'm surprised her speech is as long as
it's been
we need to come together in peace and
remember that
every life is precious
[Music]
ben carson hope he can stay up through
this
carson a retired neurosurgeon and
a public servant i hope i can before i
begin
i'd like to say that our hearts go out
to the blake family
and the other families who've been
impacted by the tragic events
in kenosha as jacob's mother
has urged the country let's use our
hearts
our love and our intelligence to work
together
to show the rest of the world how humans
are supposed to treat each other
america is great when we behave
greatly in order to succeed
and change we must first come together
in
love of our fellow citizens history
reminds us
that necessary change comes through hope
and love not senseless and destructive
violence abraham lincoln once said
to an america divided that quote
your purpose then plainly stated
is that you will destroy the government
unless you be allowed to construct it is
actually
an achievement how boring and
uninspiring ben carson's public speaking
is it actually
it seems it's difficult to be this
consistently boring right i mean it
takes some kind of i don't know that i
call it skill but consistency
today we have a choice do we want big
government
that controls our lives from cradle to
grave
or do we believe in the power and wisdom
of the
people and their ability to self-govern
with help from a limited federal
government
our president donald j trump believes
in the people he is one of us
he makes promises and he keeps them
he is transparent and we certainly know
what he's thinking
he does not submit to political
correctness
or to its enforcers the media
he is real right now
we need real we need courage
we can't cower in the corner and hope
that no one calls us a name
believing that will keep us safe that is
not
courage and that will not lead us to a
good
and just place right we must remember
all those who sacrificed everything
in order to give us freedom and we must
be willing to do the same for those who
come
after us president trump does not
dabble in identity politics he wants
everyone to succeed he believes in the
adage
a rising identity all boats
many on the other side love to incite
division
by claiming that president trump is a
racist
they could not be more wrong what a
speech years ago jesse jackson gave
donald trump
an award for the economic opportunities
he created for black people
jesse jackson in palm beach florida
donald trump led the crusade to allow
blacks and jews into private clubs and
resorts
one of the first things he did as
president trump demanded his resorts be
filled with jews
colleges and universities into the white
house
so that it could get proper attention
and financial support
before the pandemic african-american
unemployment
was at an all-time low president trump
accomplished prison reform he created
incentives to encourage investors to
become involved with
economically deprived areas of america
he strongly supports school choice
fully recognizing that no matter what
circumstances remember guys school
choice code 4 defund public schools
a good education it was true for me
when my mother forced me to read books
about
how wild is it trump has been sued for
race-based
um housing discrimination against black
people
and ben carson is his secretary of
housing
and urban development what kind of a
world do we live in
you can do anything but i will never
allow
you to become a victim
it was then that i stopped listening to
the people who were trying to convince
me
that i was a victim and that others were
responsible for my victimhood
what is racist is the fact that african
americans have the highest
abortion rate president trump is the
most pro-life
president there we go in the country's
history he will continue to fight for
those who cannot
yet speak the vision of a shining
city upon a hill came from jesus's
sermon on the mount
america is that shiny city
we are the beacon of hope for the world
at this moment in time president donald
trump
is the man with the courage the vision
and the ability to keep it
shining brightly
okay hard to tell with ben carson's
delivery when he's sort of building to
a climax in the speech uh
but it's over okay it's over
very very good if you're just joining us
we are standing by for donald trump's
convention speech
formally accepting the renomination of
the republican party scheduled for
i think about 50 minutes from now 50 60
minutes from now
um i did hear about some of the items
that
trump is going to touch on during the
speech and it's going to be a crazy
speech so
i wanted to i thought maybe we could
workshop tomorrow
our lead story on the podcast is going
to be
a review of the speech and i'm trying to
workshop the most
click-baity possible title for the
youtube clip
and i want your help some ideas i had
include
world stunned by trump convention speech
trump convention speaks speech shocks
the world
badly trump's brain fails during
historically sick speech
trump suffers historical humiliation at
the rnc
trump deeply humiliates himself during
rnc speech
uh we i would certainly work in the
phrase
visibly sweaty if it's applicable um
trump suffers mental breakdown during
speech anyway
uh give you know i'm always glad to get
ideas from people
about clever or funny like the click
baity titles
are almost a joke in and of themselves
it's not serious we we're sort of joking
around with it
but um always interested in hearing
trump suffers brain fail at historic
speed yeah suffers
brain fail that could be interesting
trump covered in sweat during global
embarrassment actually
that's not bad trump covered in sweat
during global embarrassment gr or global
shame i'm gonna make a note of that
trump covered in sweat
during global shame
slash embarrassment that's pretty solid
actually
that may really do it um
trump brain fails while you it's see you
have to keep it you can't
sometimes you can't put it all in there
because i would love brain fail
and sweat covered all together um
trump hour of lies sets global record
that could be something anyway we're
gonna figure it out
shamari vazquez says america is covered
in jesus's blood i don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing
um trump rnc speech gone sexual that
doesn't seem like at the right title for
it
no clay
clayman says hey david do you think
biden will move as far to the left as
bernie now at any point of his
presidency should he be elected
um no probably not
probably not let me say thank you to
renvax who has subscribed with twitch
prime and his
twitch subscriber look at this
1427
that's the biggest number we've ever had
from the perspective of twitch
yeah what about marinara covered trump
delivers worse speech in history that
could be something
for the clip tomorrow it wouldn't be
accurate
but um
orange trump delivers historically
terrible speech
i don't know there's so many
combinations dc blunt says david
may you ensure that my super chat was
worth five dollars by saying something
nice about new hampshire
ps brick and feather has the best double
ipa in massachusetts i'm not an ipa guy
so i wouldn't know
uh i'm i'm more into the white ales uh
and belgian style so you know what in
the u.s
is uh sometimes like ufo white or
allagash white
some of the belgian versions of that
style um
oh clementine uh clown shoes clementine
is a great beer
what else the one the one ipa i do like
is the orange line ipa
from turtle swamp brewery which is a
local brewery in the boston area that's
a that's a good one
okay continuing on oh something nice
about new hampshire
beautiful camping beautiful camping in
new hampshire i don't camp
but beautiful camping i'm told ross
pagarian says trump sniffs re-election
with rnc speech
maybe something about sniffing trump
sniffs his way through
historically disastrous speech trump
sniffs through
humiliating convention speech that's not
bad
trump sniffs through
humiliating convention speech that's a
pretty good
that could be good um
okay things are continuing here is rudy
giuliani let's see what's going on with
his head today
my name is rudy giuliani and i'm the
former mayor of new york city
evenly shaved today in 2013
my city elected a self-described
progressive democrat as mayor okay
new york city once described as
america's crime capital had become
by the mid 1990s america's safest large
city by the way sweaty sniffling trump
brain fail horrifies the world is pretty
good
my city is in shock murders shootings
and violent crime are increasing at
percentages unheard of in the past
we're seeing the return of rioting and
looting
during riots this democrat mayor like
others
has often prevented the police from
making arrests
and even when arrests are made liberal
progressive da's release the rioters
so as not to disrupt the rioting
new yorkers wonder how did we get
overwhelmed by crime
so quickly and declined so fast
don't let democrats do to america what
they have done to new york
horrible suit again the democrats are
urging you to vote
for an obviously defective candidate
biden has changed his principles so
often he no longer has any principles
he's a trojan horse with bernie aoc
pelosi black lives matter and his
party's entire left wing just
waiting to execute their pro-criminal
rudy looks like a kid in his oversized
suit
policies the whole unprecedented wave of
lawlessness
began with a truly just cause
the unforgivable police killing of
george
floyd in minneapolis
peaceful protests began all over the
land
the condemnation of the killing was
universal from president trump
was universal from president trump to
democrat leaders
it seemed for a few brief shining
moments
democrat and republican leaders would
come together
with a unified proposal to reduce police
misconduct so just so people know
tomorrow i'm going to have
a clip um discussing this idea of
violent democratically run cities
which is um very problematic and also
inaccurate and so i don't
just kind of keep that in mind tomorrow
we'll have a clip on it on the podcast
and then we'll publish it to youtube
over the weekend but that's actually a
meme
and a trope that's being repeated a lot
so i am going to address it tomorrow
they hijacked the peaceful protest into
vicious
brutal riots soon protests turned into
riots in many other american cities
almost all democrat
businesses were burned and crushed
people beaten
shot and killed police officers
routinely assaulted
badly beaten and occasionally murdered
and the police handcuffed by progressive
democrat mayors from doing anything but
observe the crimes
and absorb the blows but the worst of it
was the slaughter of innocent young
people with their whole
lives ahead of them the murder of
four-year-old legrand tal pharaoh
in kansas city shocked the nation but
not black lives matter
or there are many democrat supporters
17 year old basketball star brandon
hendricks
was killed in the bronx just days after
graduating high school
and on his way to st john's to play
basketball
he passed with only a brief mention
one-year-old david gardner jr was shot
and killed in a stroller at a cookout in
brooklyn
and it caused no outrage
for president trump and for us
republicans
all black lives matter and the lives of
legrand and
brandon davil matter to us all lives
matter to us
these continuous riots and democratic
cities
gives you a good view of the future
under biden
but trump's president five of the top
cities for homicides
like the top cities for rioting and
looting are governed by
progressive democrats
using the progressive democrat approach
to crime
which is to do nothing substantive to
reduce it
to release prisoners as many and as soon
as possible
and to go to war with the police the
only group
with the capability to protect your
citizens
it is clear that a vote for biden and
the democrats
creates the risk that you will bring
this lawlessness
to your city to your town to your suburb
there is no question that this awesome
job
of restoring safety for our people
cannot be done
from your basement joe
there's also no question that president
one quick thing
some of the shootings that rudy referred
to i've just been looking them up
the reason they get less media coverage
even though they got a ton
is that the person responsible is very
quickly arrested and charged and so
very often they play this game where
they go what about this shooting what
about that shooting that nobody's
talking about
most of the ones they're referring to
the perpetrator is almost immediately
arrested
and charged and indicted and that is a
real difference with some of the ones
where the situation is very different as
many of you know with this boundless
love of our country and
all our people his disciplined work
ethic
his exceptional ability to inspire and
his deep understanding of our system of
government
and the strength of american values is
the man
we can trust to preserve and even
improve
our way of life mr president make our
nation
safe again
really unhinged speech guys i mean just
really completely out of his mind
thanks to ken thanks to candid chaos for
subscribing with twitch prime
as well as rocky sherlock i want to say
thanks to mr of lies for subscribing
with prime with the message
pog david also father tork
has subscribed with prime and that gets
us to 1432 over on twitch which is a
beautiful number
super chats continue to come in mitch
hulbert says the rewriting of history is
amazing but this works for many people
please vote
brandon white says rudy is exhausting
um antonio muniz your opinion on latinos
for trump in one
sentence ridiculous i don't even need
one sentence i just need one word
um okay we're gonna skip a couple of
these because there are kids who who are
watching
uh super chats are coming in so quickly
i can't even keep up
trump sweats beautifully during rnc
speech is an interesting idea
jason nadal says i wonder what time slot
herman cain
would have been scheduled on if they
don't do a memorial for him that would
be sad i don't think they're going to do
a memorial for him
it would call attention to uh
coronavirus
so i don't think they're going to do
that zest the african
geriatric giuliani delivers the infamous
sermon on the mount
if trump wins bush gore style will it
lead to violence i'm addressing that
on tomorrow's uh program so i don't want
to get ahead of it
let's see who we have here oh it's tom
cotton
good lunatic senator tom cotton
a lot's changed in four years back then
we gathered in a rowdy arena
tonight you're probably at home while i
stand alone
stands alone that was the motto of my
old army unit the 506th
infantry the original band of brothers
from the normandy beaches to the iraqi
desert
we fought alongside each other but we
were always prepared
to stand alone and so it is with our
nation
we lead the free world but we'll stand
alone if we must
to defend america donald trump
understands this
he puts america first that's why america
is safer now
than four years ago but joe biden would
return us to
it's weird because the last speaker rudy
talked about how dangerous the country
is
and why that means we need to reelect
trump cotton saying the country's safer
than ever
major national security decision over
the past four decades so
let's compare the records of joe biden
and donald trump
joe biden slashed defense spending again
and again
president trump rebuilt our military and
added the space force
joe biden let isis terrorists rampage
across the middle east
president trump eliminated isis's leader
and destroyed its caliphate
joe biden opposed the mission to kill
osama bin laden
president trump avenged the murder of
hundreds of americans
by killing iran's terrorist mastermind
qasim suleimani
joe biden sent pallets of cash to the
ayatollahs
pallets president trump ripped up the
dangerous iran nuclear deal
joe biden treated israel like a nuisance
president trump moved our embassy to
jerusalem
and brokered peace deals in the middle
east
joe biden coddled socialist dictators in
cuba and venezuela
president trump fights against communism
in america's backyard
and around the world and on the
communist party of china
there is no comparison joe biden
aided and abetted china's rise for 50
years
with terrible trade deals that closed
our factories and laid off our workers
president trump stands up to china's
cheating
and stealing and lying joe biden allowed
chinese fentanyl to flood across our
southern border
president trump sanctioned chinese drug
dealers for poisoning our kids
joe biden said chinese communists aren't
even our competitor
aren't bad folks by the way that one
line sanctioned chinese
drug dealers is a crazy line and we
could talk for 10
minutes about that but i'm not going to
do it right now and he's threat and he
is making
china pay but china's not giving up in
fact they're rooting for joe biden
america's other enemies won't give up
either
but joe biden would be as wrong and weak
over the next four years as he has been
for the last
50. we need a president who stands up
for america
not one who takes a knee a strong and
proud america
is a safe america safe from our enemies
and
safe from war no one who's seen the face
of war
desires to see it again too many of our
fellow americans are
already honored at the hallowed grounds
of arlington
but if we want peace we must be strong
weakness is provocative president
trump's
strength has kept us out of war
joe biden won't stand up for america
donald trump
will delusion this november let's stand
with the president
and vote to keep america great
yeah tom cotton is if you start with
pete buttige
you pull him and stretch him out
vertically but then
compress his face a face from the
standpoint of with that's how you get
tom cotton you start with bootage that's
how you end up
okay let's see who we have here um
not exactly sure who this is
this is my husband carl our daughter
kayla was taken as a hostage and
murdered by isis
from a young age kayla was amazing she
taught herself languages
how to write music how to play guitar
she worked with troubled youth military
veterans
and native americans everywhere kayla
went people smiled kayla had a gift to
be able to see the world
through someone else's eyes she became a
humanitarian aid worker
and when she was helping children at an
orphanage in india
kayla wrote i find god
in the suffering eyes reflected in mine
if this is how you were revealed to me
this is how i will forever seek you
she went to turkey to help syria okay
with absolute total peace and love that
this is horrible i'm gonna
just step away a little bit from this
speech typically i've been
covering the major speeches from elected
officials and and a couple of others and
i do want to get some messages
in from you guys because you guys have a
lot to say
and uh messages are coming in via twitch
via super chat
master krepta said via twitch they are
coming for the suburbs who's they
i think they mean black people right is
that is that
crazy to say that it's all been about
they're not gonna allow too many
minorities into the suburbs that's the
gist i've been getting from this entire
suburbs thing from from day one that was
my instinct
tell me if i'm wrong um tony crump says
what will trump do if he loses the
election
up until january 20th i that's a real
question
that's a real question and and he it
could go two ways he could go completely
crazy and unhinged
or if trump loses in november during the
the lame duck period he might just
recede into you know
not leaving the residence at the at the
white house and watching tv
uh just go travel says u.s stands alone
and are not welcome in the european
union
unfortunately that is increasingly the
case it is not good
chakaseki has a suggestion for
tomorrow's review of trump's speech
upcoming glistening
and glowering trump gibbers gaffes and
grovels
for another presidential term not bad
a kyle macero says these people are
living in a fantasy world that's unreal
it is unreal
junior balogan says if we had actual
leaders then trump would have brought
all needed groups together to address
the issue of racial injustice
instead of sending more troops of course
of course trump is not a leader
colonel angus says what did you eat for
lunch there's a stain on your shirt oh
my god is that for real
no i just put this shirt on anyway so it
wouldn't have been it wouldn't there
would be no lunch stain
wait a second there's something in the
reflection that that is weird it looks
like something's on it
no but there's nothing on it uh i had a
corned beef sandwich actually
for lunch and a great great salad corned
beef from uh from michael's deli in
brookline which i mentioned yesterday
they're not a sponsor that's just where
the corned beef happens to be from
jason smith says crowds are gathering
outside the white house maybe we can
hear them during trump's speech
tristan mccoppen says trump said hillary
was on drugs in 2016 do you remember
no that i don't remember i remember he
said he was going to lock her up
but i don't remember him saying she was
uh she was on drugs but maybe i'm just
forgetting
um if you're just joining us as we
approach the top of the hour we are
down to the last 70 minutes of the
republican national convention
um praise be to whoever or whatever
after this we don't need to do this for
another four years and that's a
beautiful thing because it has been
horrible it has been
truly horrible and if you're a member
you can listen to today's bonus show or
watch today's bonus show where
i actually discuss this convention has
fatigued me from politics
more than any politically related event
that i can remember
and it's going to be a really really
good thing
when this is over it's it's it's been
bad it's been bad
super guy says if trump loses he will
just quit and resign
i doubt it i doubt that he will
i don't think his uh narcissism will
would allow him to do that
um people asking if there are videos of
the previous
evenings of this yes on youtube and
twitch you can go back and watch the
broadcasts from the previous evenings
oh and sorry i got interrupted so
expecting donald trump to speak
supposedly between 10 20 and 10 30
p.m eastern time which is about 30 40
minutes from now
and it will be at the white house there
are reportedly no masks required
no coronavirus tests and very little if
any
social distancing so it could become a
super spreader event tyler in the
residence says pogchamps 2 champion
white shirt walter yeah a streamer known
as xqc
nicknamed me white shirt walter because
i had a different white shirt on
the other day during my pogchamps match
lars solomon says regarding party
conventions who decides which party gets
to go first
i think that the incumbent president's
party
always goes second can anybody fact
check me is that true
my my just vague recollection is that
the incumbent party always goes second
people aren't sure okay
uh all right i guess we don't
necessarily have an answer there
great thank you
[Music]
okay so it looks like next they're going
to be going into the alice johnson's
speech alice johnson is a woman who was
in
prison um for a drug sentence
donald trump heard about her i believe
through kim kardashian
uh this is this is real as far as i know
and decided
to commute her sentence and
um has been trying to get as much
political mileage out of it as
absolutely possible and continuing to do
that tonight
thanks to he went to jared for
subscribing with twitch prime with the
message
hi david you're cool um
kit leah steele also subscribing with
prime
jimba bass says le puedes
thanks david we enjoy your show yes very
much saludos samantha
very much appreciate you watching i do
speak spanish let's take a listen to
this
grace of god and the compassion of
president
donald john trump i stand before you
tonight
and i assure you i'm not a ghost
i am alive i am well
and most importantly i am
free in 1996
i began serving time in prison life
plus 25 years i had never been in
trouble
i was a first time non-valid offender
what i did was wrong i made decisions
that i regret some say
you do the crime you do the time however
that time should be fair and just
we've all made mistakes none of us want
to be defined forever
based on our worst decision while in
prison
i became a playwright a mentor a
certified hospice volunteer an ordained
minister
and received the special olympics event
coordinator of the year award for my
work with disabled women
because the only thing worse than
unjustly imprisoning my body
is trying to imprison my mind
my transformation was described as
extraordinary truth is
there are thousands of people just like
me who deserve the opportunity to come
home
i never stopped fighting for my freedom
my christian faith and the prayers of so
many
kept hope alive when president trump
heard about me
about the injustice of my story
he saw me as a person
guys let's be honest it's not the story
that moved trump
it's the fact that it was kim kardashian
who told him about it
president trump but free in man
thanks to the almighty god
i couldn't believe it i always
remembered that god knew my name
even in my darkest hour but i never
thought a president would
when i was released on june 6 2018
i ran across that road and hugged my
grandchildren for the first time
i'll never forget that feeling and then
i remembered the promise i had made to
the men and women
i left behind that i would never stop
fighting for them
and i haven't i'm using my voice to tell
their stories
and i pray that my face reminds you
of those forgotten faces
six months after president trump granted
me a second chance
he signed the first step act into law
it was real justice reform and it
brought
joy hope and freedom to thousands of
well-deserving people
hallelujah my faith in justice and mercy
was
rewarded imagine getting to
hug your loved ones again and to think
this first step meant
so much to so many i
can't wait because we're just getting
started
the nearly 22 years i spent in prison
were not wasted god had a purpose and a
plan for my life
i was not delayed or denied
i was destined for such a time as this
i pray that you will not just hear this
message
but that you will be inspired by my
story
and your compassion will lead you to
take action
for those who are forgotten that's
what our president donald trump did for
me
and for that i will be forever
grateful god bless you
god bless president trump and
god bless america
her story is a powerful story and indeed
her sentence was unfair and it's part of
the the war on drugs that that we're
trying to deal with
um but what's important is not to
let emotion overcome judgment because
letting pardoning people because kanye
and
and kim tell you hey here's a story is
not policy
and that would not you know if he gets
one of those
a month for his entire presidency and
says let's pardon this person
that's not a policy change and i think
it's just important to uh
bear that in mind um regardless of the
individual stories
thanks to feels melancholy hassium for
subscribing on twitch
transcen has subscribed and says david
do you believe that republicans are so
hyperbolic
because they have nothing substantive to
talk about or because they rule by fear
it's really both it's really both it's a
combination of the two
um
okay kyle macero says progressivism in
the heart and so is the heart and soul
of america not conservatism
modern-day republicans would have
absolutely been loyalists back
in the 18th century
juan diego munoz says hey david your
spanish sounds kind of spaniard i'm
actually argentinian
um not spanish patty e
says anyone else getting a telethon vibe
tonight it's not just tonight
it's not just tonight let me thank a
couple of people who signed up on my
website so that i don't fall too far
behind we have an aggressive goal of 51
i'm sorry 59 website members let's see
where we can get
christian ventura is number 22.
elizabeth mock
is number 23. a brazan is number 24
hiyambu laosher is number 25 mark
oppenheimer is number 26 chris pettit 27
heather mcintosh is number 28 and kyle
barnhart is number 29.
right at about the halfway mark there
remember that in addition to the coupon
code 2020 now there's a
secret coupon code okay we
celebrated the 15th anniversary of the
show in some shape or form on sunday
the code is 15 year 1 5 year
it's an even bigger discount than 2020
now
it is active and by all means
feel free to take advantage of it
you have not people wondering if they're
they've missed trump you have not missed
trump trump is the
closer he's the keynote and he is
scheduled
it could be 20 minutes from now it could
be 30
it could be 40. somewhere uh somewhere
in that range would be my expectation
spicy meat paul says via super chat
this has been historically grotesque
thanks for being our de facto guide
through the hypocritical swamp
david my pleasure i appreciate everybody
who's here
um oh here's an unusual message church
of debra
sends a super chat you look so cute
david grandma deborah loves you
thanks grandma appreciate that
um susan green says she's here of
seeking
here sick of hearing about god and
christians
joey two times says how funny would it
be if trump finally had a moment of
clarity
and went all bullworth on us i would not
expect it
shea no oh whoa you almost got me there
you almost got me there
shea says try concealer to hide your
oily and pimply skin
neither is a problem that i have i don't
know if you're referring to the um
to the speakers this evening but that is
that is not a problem i have at all
look at that smooth even skin it's quite
a thing i'll tell you no but that's not
a problem i have i did have a problem
like that when i was 14. um but
fortunately not a problem i have right
now i appreciate the super chat though
um kyle hopper says what's your hue
prediction for trump tonight let me see
if i can find that
uh names for orange shades
let's see if we can find this will
actually be useful
i might even tweet this in a little bit
because this is actually pretty
interesting
shades of orange okay um
[Music]
orange color wheel orange web color dark
orange
safety orange inner no it's not really
any of these
papaya whip i think trump might be like
a dark papaya whip
certainly possible not really peach
light orange apricot not melon no
it's too perfect right atomic tangerine
i think trump is going to be atomic
tangerine tonight for sure
yeah that's the color i'm i'm expecting
okay here is
ivanka is this live who the hell knows
good evening
by the way is there a pandemic doesn't
seem like it send a special
message to everyone who's been affected
by hurricane laura
our hearts are with you the president
will continue
to support you every step of the way and
just like americans always do the nation
will come together
to help you rebuild your homes
businesses and communities
stronger and more resilient than ever
before
four years ago i introduced to you a
builder
an entrepreneur an outsider and the
people's nominee
for president of the united states
tonight i stand before you
as the proud daughter of the oh my god
the crowd
he is our commander-in-chief champion
of the american worker defender
of common sense and our voice for the
forgotten men and women of this country
he is our president and my father donald
j trump is she introducing him now or is
this just a generic speech
this evening i want to tell you about
the leader i know
and the moments i wish every american
could see
i want to tell you the story of a
president who is fighting for you
from dawn to midnight when the cameras
have left who's she talking about
they're off and the decisions really
count
when jared and i moved with our three
young children to washington
we didn't exactly know what we were in
for but our kids
our kids loved it from the start my son
joseph
promptly built grandpa a lego replica of
the white house
the president still displays it on the
mantle in the oval office right over
there
so that he can show world leaders just
so they know
not enough blacks the greatest
grandchildren on earth
i agree
over the last four years we've learned a
lot
i've seen in washington it's easy for
politicians to survive if they silence
their convictions and skipped the hard
fights
i couldn't believe so many politicians
actually prefer
to complain about a problem rather than
fix it
i was shocked to see people leave major
challenges unsolved
so they can blame the other side
campaign on the same issue
in the next election but donald trump
did not come to washington to win praise
from the beltway elites
donald trump came to washington for one
reason
and one reason alone to make america
great again i thought it was to line his
own pockets and feed his ego
by the way the irresponsibility of this
crowd in the middle of a pandemic not
tested no masks
leaves and he says what he thinks
whether you agree with him or not you
always know where he stands
i recognize that my dad's communication
style is
not to everyone's taste and i know that
his tweets can feel
a bit unfiltered but the results
the results speak for themselves
they certainly do
he is so unapologetic about his beliefs
that he has caused
me and countless americans to take a
hard look at our own convictions
and ask ourselves what do we stand for
what kind of america do we want to leave
for our children
i am more certain than ever before we
want a future where our kids can believe
in american greatness we want a society
where every child can live in a safe
community
and go to a great school of their choice
we want a culture where differences of
opinion and debate
are encouraged not cancelled where law
enforcement is respected
where our country's rich diversity is
celebrated
and where people of all backgrounds
races genders and creeds
have the chance to achieve their
god-given potential
this is the future my father is working
to build
each and every day okay
building after all is what he's done his
whole life
he has admired and befriended
construction workers on countless job
sites
but it has been a new and profound
experience for him
and for me to see these stoic machinists
and steel workers
come to him with a tear in their eye and
thank him for being the only person
willing to go to the mat for them for
their jobs for their families and for
their futures
to the hard-working men and women across
america and here tonight
you are the reason my father fights with
all of his heart and all of his might
you are the reason he ran for president
in the first place
and you are the reason he is going to
keep fighting
for four more years
okay oh is that mnuchin oh my god
she seems so pleased with herself
four more years how do you justify an
event of this size in the middle of a
pandemic with no
tests and no masks and how do you even
justify
a political event like this at the white
house how do you justify ivanka speak
i mean everything that's going on here
is vile
the bad trade deals that had gutted
millions of middle-class jobs
most of his advisors argued that the
economy was so strong
following our historic tax and
regulatory cuts
that it didn't make sense to risk
rocking the boat
after the meeting as i walked with my
father back towards the residence he
said
you know the reason this has never been
done before is because our leaders
haven't had the guts
when the economy is good they settle for
good and when things are bad
they don't have the will or ability so
they kick the can until it's someone
else's problem
he was right if my father didn't take on
these fights no one would
in the months that followed president
trump refused
to settle for a good deal he wanted a
great deal and
ultimately that is exactly what we got
i remember each time he was updated on
the progress of the new trade deal with
mexico and canada
he would say don't let down those dairy
farmers i met in wisconsin
i don't want them to like this deal i
want them to
love it
[Laughter]
today in the midst of this unprecedented
global pandemic
it's more clear than ever that our
president was absolutely correct to take
on trade when he did
and bring our jobs nice factories and
our life-saving medicines
back to the usa
as our nation endures this grave trial
i pray for the families who are mourning
the loss of a loved one
for those who are battling covet 19 and
for the first responders
and the healthcare heroes who remain on
the front line of this fight
the grief sorrow and anxiety during this
time
is felt by all i've been with my father
and i've seen the pain in his eyes when
he receives updates on the lives that
have been stolen by this plague
i have witnessed him make some of the
most difficult decisions of his life
i sat with him in the oval office as he
stopped travel to europe
i watched him take the strongest most
inclusive economy in a lifetime
the lowest unemployment in a half
century and the highest wage increase
for working families
in decades and close it down to save
american lives
it is why our president rapidly
mobilized the full force of government
in the private sector to produce
ventilators within weeks to build the
most robust testing system in the world
and to develop safe and effective
treatments and very
very soon a vaccine my father isn't
deterred
by defeatist thinkers the word
impossible
well it only motivates him donald trump
rejects the cynical notion
that this country's greatest
achievements are behind us
he believes that nothing is beyond our
reach
and that the best is yet to come
i have seen all of my life how my dad
believes in the potential of each
individual
earlier this evening we were all
inspired by the incredible testimony of
alice johnson
a great grandmother who was sentenced to
life in prison for a first-time
nonviolent drug offense i was with my
father when he decided to commute
alice's life sentence
together we watched alice leave prison
after nearly
22 years as she ran into the arms of her
family and they celebrated a joyful
reunion
my father got very quiet i could see the
emotion on his face
after a long silence he looked at me and
said imagine how many people there are
just like alice right but
we're still waging the war on drugs
silenced in our prison system
president trump rectified the
disparities of the 1994
biden crime bill that disproportionately
hurt
african americans
against all odds he brought together
republicans and democrats and passed
the most significant criminal justice
reform of
our generation and we're just getting
started
my father did not care people wondering
why i'm not fact checking it's
impossible to keep up i mean what's the
point you know it's just like i'm just
trying to kind of take in the gist of
the entire thing but
it's it's it's a herculean task to try
to fact check something like this
the ability to build consensus
bipartisan success
will help heal our country's racial
inequities and bring us forward
together president
trump is advancing the american values
of work and family
four years ago in cleveland i said
president trump would deliver
for working women last year over 70
percent
of all new jobs were secured by women
four years ago i told you my father
would focus on making child care
affordable and accessible
in president trump's first term we
secured the largest ever increase for
child care funding
giving more than 800 000 low-income
families great child care
at a cost they can afford as part of
republican tax cuts in 2019
alone our child tax credit put over two
thousand dollars
into the pockets of 40 million american
families
democrat politicians recently introduced
a plan to increase the child tax credit
yet when i was fighting less than three
years ago at the president's direction
to get
congress to double the child tax credit
not a single democrat
voted to pass the law we got it done
anyway
okay four years ago i promised that
president trump would support
mothers in the workforce in his first
year in office he signed into law the
first ever
national paid leave tax credit today
eight million more americans have access
to this benefit
okay four years ago i said that
americans needed an economy that permits
people to rise again
during president trump's first three
years in office 72 percent
of all new jobs went to americans who
had been
outside of the workforce
four years ago i told you i would fight
alongside my father and four years later
here i am
she's so pleased with herself
many of the issues my father has
championed are not historically
republican priorities yet where
washington chooses sides
our president chooses common sense where
politicians choose party
our president chooses people
what a vapid line truly since the day he
took the oath of office i've watched my
father take on the failed policies of
the past and do what no
leader has done before recently he took
dramatic
action to cut the cost of prescription
drugs despite fielding angry calls
from the ceos of nearly every major
pharmaceutical company
now when we see attack ads paid for by
big pharma
my dad smiles and says to me
you know we're doing something really
right if they're hitting us so hard
man ivanka's really delusional i didn't
realize how delusional she was
that american crops were going to waste
because food supply chains were
disrupted by the virus
he directed secretary perdue and me to
find a way to get this nutritious food
fresh fruit vegetables meat and dairy to
families
most in need within a matter of days we
launched the farmers to family food box
program
which has now delivered over a hundred
million
meals to into the house why is she
working with secretary perdue she's not
even supposed to be involved in the
administration due to anti-nepotism laws
to protect the most vulnerable among us
i've worked alongside the president
as he signed into law nine pieces of
legislation
to combat the evil of human trafficking
human trafficking is bad that's true
i've stood by my father's side at dover
air force base as he's received our
fallen heroes
and each time it has steeled his resolve
to
finally stop finally stop the endless
foreign wars
to change the paradigm in the middle
east he took a fresh approach
he hasn't actually done that leaders beg
him not to move the american embassy to
jerusalem
yet he delivered on a promise also made
and
unfulfilled by past presidents because
my father knew that it was the right
thing to do
defying all expectations just weeks ago
he rewrote history again by making a
peace agreement
in the middle east the biggest
breakthrough
in a quarter century
if it's already this bad the trump
speech is going to be historic
i hope people are ready for the first
time
in a long time we have a president who
has called out washington's hypocrisy
and they hate him for it
dad people attack you for being
unconventional
but i love you for being real and i
respect you
for being effective
our president refuses to surrender his
beliefs to score point with the
political elite to my father you are the
elite
you are the only people he cares about
scoring points with
if these problems were easy to solve
previous presidents would have done so
but you don't achieve different results
by doing things
the same way washington has not changed
donald trump
donald trump has changed washington
america doesn't need another empty
vessel who will do whatever the media
and the fringe of his party demands
now more than ever america needs four
more years of a warrior
in the white house
tonight i could not be more proud to
introduce my father
a man i know was made for this moment in
history oh she is introducing my fellow
americans
our first lady and the 45th president
of the united states oh god donald j
trump
oh my god guys listen
this is the last time we have to do this
we don't have to have another republican
convention for four years
and we never have to have another trump
speech
uh i see people are coming in now um
approaching 13 000 viewers on youtube
and uh
over 2200 on twitch i we're all gonna
suffer through this and then this is it
okay so let's just keep that in mind i
see the super chats
uh like a simpsons episode the magnitude
of delusion
is frightening i see it all i see it all
my friends
it is really really bad and uh
tomorrow we will have um a review of
what we are about to see
it is going to be really bad i don't you
know i know people say they're drinking
every time trump does x those are very
dangerous games i don't encourage the
binge drinking
but i understand the feeling and this is
going to be
i i expect a degree of delusion that
would be
clinically relevant uh for the field of
mental health
by the way the country music pandering
it's like
dude trump's from queens okay trump
doesn't like country music
and just every aspect of this is just
pandering after pandering
[Applause]
[Music]
sociologists psychologists
historians
political scientists this is going to be
an era for them to study to figure out
what happened what happened in the
united states
during this time
[Music]
it's still going by the way i don't know
that we've ever seen trump this shade of
orange either i don't know that we this
is a new one for me certainly
thanks tim for the membership the
numbers are up today
we've not fallen ah thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
friends delegates and distinguished
guests please
i stand before you tonight honored by
your support
proud of the extraordinary progress we
have made together over the last
four incredible years and brimming with
confidence
in the bright future we will build for
america
over the next four years
we begin this evening our thoughts
are with the wonderful people who have
just come
through the wrath of hurricane laura
we are working closely with state and
local officials
in texas louisiana arkansas mississippi
sparing no effort to save lives
while the hurricane was fierce one of
the strongest to make landfall
in 150 years the casualties
and damage were far less than thought
possible
only 24 hours ago
weak applause line and this is due to
the great work of
fema law enforcement and the
individual states i will be going
this weekend and congratulations
thank you for that great job out there
we really appreciate it
we are one national family and we will
always
protect love and care for each other
here tonight are the people who have
made my journey possible
and filled my life with so much joy
for her incredible service to our nation
and its children
i want to thank our magnificent first
lady
remember we're expecting tapes of her
absolutely unloading on trump and ivanka
to be published in the next couple weeks
i also want to thank my amazing daughter
ivanka for that introduction
and to all of my children ivanka please
stand up
thank you
and to all of my children and
grandchildren i love you more than words
can express
i know my brother robert is looking down
on us
right now from heaven he was a great
brother
and was very proud of the job
we are all doing thank you we love you
robert
let us also take a moment to show our
profound appreciation
for a man who has always fought by our
side
and stood up for our values a man of
deep faith
pence and steadfast conviction
our vice president mike pence
such theater
such vile theater
something's up with his face mike is
joined by his beloved wife
a teacher and military mom karen pence
thank you
oh my fellow americans tonight with a
heart full of gratitude and boundless
optimism
i accept i profoundly accept this
nomination
for president of the united states
this is a cult this is a cult yes
you are correct
the republican party the party of
abraham lincoln goes forward united
determined and ready to welcome millions
of democrats
independents and anyone who believes in
the greatness of
america and the righteous heart
of the american people
that thing's happening where he's sort
of lost in the prompter and doesn't know
what he's saying
build the greatest economy in history
quickly returning
to full employment soaring incomes
and record prosperity
we will defend america against all
threats
and protect america against all dangers
we will lead america into new frontiers
of ambition
and discovery and we will reach
for new heights of national achievement
we will rekindle new faith in our values
new pride in our history
and a new spirit of unity that can only
be realized through love
for our great country
we understand that america is not a land
cloaked in darkness
america is the torch that enlightens the
entire world
okay gathered here at our beautiful and
majestic
white house known all over the world as
the people's house
we cannot help but marvel at the miracle
that is our great american story
this has been the home of larger than
life figures like teddy roosevelt
and andrew jackson who rallied americans
to bold visions of a bigger and brighter
future
within these walls lived tenacious
generals
like president grant and eisenhower
who led our soldiers in the cause of
freedom
from these grounds thomas jefferson
sent lewis and clark on a daring
expedition to cross a wild
and uncharted continent in the depths
of a bloody civil war he doesn't know
what he's president
abraham lincoln looked out
these very windows upon a half-completed
washington monument and asked god
in his providence to save our nation
two weeks after pearl harbor franklin
delano roosevelt welcomed
winston churchill and just inside
they set our people on a course to
victory in the second world war
in recent months our nation
and the entire planet has been struck by
a new and powerful
invisible enemy by the way
do people hear the sirens from the
protests that are happening
challenge we are delivering life-saving
therapies and will
produce a vaccine before the end of the
year
or maybe even sooner
[Music]
the crowd doesn't even seem to care that
much about dealing with coronavirus
they're just
in their minds it's over never before
who masks
what united generations past was an
unshakable confidence
in america's destiny and an unbreakable
faith
in the american people they knew that
our country is blessed by god
and has a special purpose in this world
it is that conviction that inspired the
formation of our union
our westward expansion
the abolition of slavery the passage of
civil rights
the space program and the overthrow of
fascism tyranny and communism
this towering american spirit has
prevailed over every challenge
and lifted us to the summit of human
endeavor and yet despite all of our
greatness as a nation everything
we have achieved is now in danger
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
that may well be that may well be
thank you at no time before
have voters faced a clearer choice
between two parties
two visions two philosophies
or two agendas this election will decide
whether we save the american dream
or whether we allow a socialist agenda
to demolish our
cherished destiny the persistent air
horns are a nice touch
it will decide whether we rapidly create
millions of high-paying jobs
or whether we crush our industries and
send millions of these jobs overseas
as has foolishly been done for many
decades
your vote will decide whether we protect
law-abiding americans
or whether we give free rein to
violent anarchists and agitators and
criminals
who threaten our citizens
and this election will decide whether we
will defend the american way of life or
whether we will allow a
radical movement to completely dismantle
and destroy it if he says marxists all
have bingo
at the democrat national convention joe
biden and his party repeatedly assailed
america as a land of racial economic
and social injustice
so tonight i ask you a simple question
how can the democrat party ask to lead
our country
when it spends so much time tearing down
our country
in the left's backward view they do not
see america as the most free
just and exceptional nation on earth
instead they see a wicked nation that
must be punished
for its sins our opponents say that
redemption for you can only come
from giving power to them this is a
tired anthem spoken by every repressive
movement
throughout history but in this country
we don't look to
career politicians for salvation in
america we don't turn to government
to restore our souls we put our faith in
almighty god
imagine being barren and being like you
know we nev we were never religious up
until three and a half years ago this is
so weird for me i guess now i'm
religious i don't know because
seoul he is the destroyer of america's
jobs
and have given the chance he will be the
destroyer
of american greatness for 47 years joe
biden
took the donations of blue-collar
workers
gave them hugs and even kisses
is that supposed to be funny
and told them he felt their pain
and then he flew back to washington and
voted to ship
our jobs to china and many other
distant lands joe biden spent his entire
career
outsourcing their dreams
and the dreams of american workers
offshoring their jobs opening their
borders
and sending their sons and daughters to
fight
in endless foreign wars
wars that never ended
four years ago i ran for president
because president because i could not
watch this betrayal
of our country any longer i could not
sit by
as career politicians let other
countries take advantage of
us on trade borders foreign policy and
national defense
our nato partners as an example
were very far behind in their defense
payments
but at my strong urging
they agreed to pay 130 billion dollars
more a year the first time in over 20
years that they
upped their payments
and this 100. the average blue-collar
guy working at a factory in ohio care
about nato
i mean when we talk about voting issues
and non-voting issues is that is that a
relevant question
general stoltenberg who heads nato
was amazed after watching for so many
years and said that president trump
did what no one else was able to do
thank you
from the moment i left my former life
behind
and it was a good life
i have done nothing but fight for you i
did what our political establishment
never expected
and could never forgive breaking the
cardinal rule of washington politics
i kept my promise which one
together we have ended the rule of the
failed political class
and they are desperate to get their
power back
by any means necessary you've seen that
they are angry at me because instead of
putting them first i very simply
said america first
thank you days after taking office we
shocked the washington establishment and
withdrew from the
last administration's job-killing
trans-pacific
partnership
i then immediately approve the keystone
xl
and dakota access pipelines nightmare
ended the unfair and very costly paris
climate accord
embarrassed and secured for the first
time
american energy independence
trying to rehabilitate coal
we passed record-setting tax and
regulation cuts
at a rate nobody had ever seen before
within three short years we built the
strongest economy
in the history of the world washington
insiders asked me not to
stand up to china they pleaded with me
to let china continue stealing our jobs
ripping us off and robbing our country
blind
but i kept my word to the american
people
we took the toughest boldest strongest
and hardest hitting action against china
in american history
by far
they said that it would be impossible to
terminate and replace nafta
but again they were wrong earlier this
year
i ended the nafta nightmare and signed
the
brand new u.s mexico canada agreement
into law
i do think visibly sweaty will probably
end up being accurate by the end of the
night
building their plants and factories in
america
not firing their employees and not
deserting us
for other countries
in perhaps no area did the washington
special interest try harder to stop us
than on my policy of pro-american
immigration
but i refuse to back down and today
america's borders are
more secure than ever before
thank you we ended catch and release
stopped asylum fraud took down
human traffickers who prey on women and
children
and we have deported twenty thousand
gang members and five
hundred thousand criminal aliens
we have already built 300 miles of
border wall
and we are adding 10 new miles every
single week
the war will soon be complete and it is
working beyond our wildest
expectations
we are joined this evening by members of
the border patrol union
representing our country's courageous
border agents
thank you very much for being here thank
you brave
brave people
okay
man you see this country loves
our law enforcement they do
thank you they really do
love and respect a couple of people
standing i learned that the tennessee
valley authority laid off hundreds of
american workers
and forced them to train their lower
paid foreign replacement
i promptly removed the chairman of the
board
and now those talented american workers
have been rehired
and are back providing power to georgia
alabama tennessee kentucky mississippi
north carolina and virginia
they have their old jobs back and some
are here with us this evening please
stand you went through a lot
please stand thank you thank you very
much
you've been through a lot take a please
clap moment of service
last month i took on big pharma
you think that's easy it's not and
signed orders that will massively lower
the cost of your prescription drugs
and give critically ill patients access
to life-saving cures
we passed the decade's long-awaited
right to try right to try
we also passed va accountability and va
choice
that's an obamacare veterans we're
taking care of our veterans
remember veterans choices and obama
policy from 2014 google it my friends
this month the va given by our veterans
first time anything like that's ever
happened
by the end of my first term we will have
approved more than
300 federal judges including two great
new
supreme court justices
that's true and a real urgent reason to
get him out
and to bring prosperity to our forgotten
inner cities
we worked hard to pass historic criminal
justice reform
prison reform opportunity zones
and long-term funding of historically
black colleges and universities
and before the china virus came in
produced the best
unemployment numbers for african
americans hispanic americans and
asian americans ever recorded
sick what's going on there
and i say very modestly that i have done
more for the african-american community
than any president since
abraham lincoln oh no our first
republican president he said it again
and i have done more in three years for
the black community
than joe biden has done in 47 years
and when i'm reelected the best is yet
to come
right i would rap if i were trump but i
think we're only halfway in
thank you very much
[Applause]
when i took office the middle east was
in total chaos
isis was rampaging iran was on the rise
and the war in afghanistan had no end in
sight
i withdrew from the terrible one-sided
iran nuclear deal
disastrous president precedent rather
well both
but precedent to remove from a deal
where the other side is sticking to the
agreement makes us an untrustworthy
negotiating partner
which obviously under trump we are
but not only did we talk about it as a
future site
we got it built rather than spending
one billion dollars on a new building as
planned
we took an already owned existing
building in a better location
real estate deal right
and opened it at a cost of less than
five hundred thousand dollars
many things like that that government is
doing right now
we also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
and this month we achieved the first
middle east peace deal in 25 years
thank you to uae thank you to
israel
all these people pretending to care and
understand
diplomatic relations between israel and
the emirates is is interesting
killed it's found but when he says jump
everybody says how high ooh
bakar al-baghdadi
[Music]
then in a separate operation we
eliminated the world's number one
terrorist by far
kasim solomini still can't pronounce it
wow
must have said it a thousand times can't
say it
unlike previous administrations i have
kept america out of new wars
and our troops are coming home
he just bragged about bombing iran and
then bragged about keeping us out of
new wars completely rebuilding our
military
which was very badly depleted when i
took office as you know
this includes three separate pay raises
for our great warriors
we also launched the space force
the first new branch of the united
states military since the air force was
created almost 75
years ago and what exactly are they
doing we have spent the last four years
reversing the damage joe biden inflicted
over the last
47 years biden's record
is a shameful roll call of the most
catastrophic betrayals and blunders
in our lifetime he has spent his entire
career on the wrong side of history
biden voted for the nafta disaster the
single worst trade deal
ever enacted he supported china's entry
into the world trade organization one of
the greatest economic
disasters of all time you guys hear the
cro
after those biden calamities the united
states lost one in four manufacturing
jobs
we laid off workers in michigan ohio
new hampshire pennsylvania and many
other states
they didn't want to hear biden's hollow
words of empathy
they wanted their jobs back
as vice president he supported the
trans-pacific partnership
which would have been a death sentence
for
the u.s auto industry he backed
the horrendous south korea trade deal
which took many jobs from our country
and which i've reversed and made a great
deal for our country
he repeatedly supported mass amnesty
for illegal immigrants he voted for the
iraq war
he opposed the mission to take out osama
bin laden
he opposed killing solomani so let me
just pick one of those just to do a
little explain to you how it's
manipulative
he he says biden opposed killing bin
laden
biden believed that we needed to hold
off
to confirm it was really bin laden
before doing it
okay understand how deceptive every
single one of these claims is
china would own our country if joe biden
got elected
unlike biden i will hold them fully
accountable
for the tragedy that they caused all
over the world they caused
in recent months our nation in the world
has been hit by the
once-in-a-century pandemic that china
allowed to spread around the globe
they could have stopped it but they
allowed it to come out
we are grateful to be joined tonight by
several of our incredible nurses and
first responders
please stand and accept our profound
thanks and gratitude
many americans including me
have sadly lost friends and cherished
loved ones
to this horrible disease as one nation
we mourn we grieve and we hold in our
hearts forever the memories of all of
those lives
that have been so tragically taken so
unnecessary
in their honor we will unite in their
memory
we will overcome and when the china
virus hit
we launched the largest national
mobilization since world war ii
invoking the defense production act we
remember arguably the worst response of
any major country in the world
a single american who has needed a
ventilator has been denied a ventilator
which is a miracle
good job heading the task force
by our great vice president thank you
very much mark please
please stand up
we shipped hundreds of millions of
masked gloves and gowns to our front
line health care workers
to protect our nation's seniors we rush
supplies
testing kits and personal to
nursing homes we gave everything you can
possibly give and we're still giving it
because we're taking care
of our senior citizens
the army corps of engineers built field
hospitals
and the navy deployed our great hospital
ships
we developed from scratch the largest
and most advanced testing system
anywhere in the world america has tested
more
than every country in europe put
together
and more than every nation in the
western hemisphere combined think of
that
we have conducted 40 million more tests
than the next
closest nation which is india
we developed a wide array of effective
treatments including a powerful antibody
treatment known as convalescent plasma
you say there it is
on sunday night plasma making an
appearance that will save
thousands and that by the way aside from
plasma
um fda director admitted on monday that
on the sunday press briefing he
overhyped
it it's already been admitted fda
director look it up covered it on the
program
by 80 percent since april 80
the united states is among the lowest
case fatality rates
of any major country anywhere in the
world
the european union's case fatality rate
is nearly three
times higher than ours but you don't
hear that they don't write about that
they don't want to write about that they
don't want you
to know those things all together the
nations of europe
have experienced a 30 percent greater
increase in excess mortality
than the united states think of that we
enacted the largest package of financial
relief
in american history thanks to our
paycheck protection program
we have saved or supported more than 50
million american jobs that's one of the
reasons that we're
advancing so rapidly with our economy
superchat i'm going to turn this into a
tweet as a result we have seen the
smallest
economic contraction of any major
western nation
and we are recovering at a much faster
rate than
anybody over the past three months
we have gained over nine million jobs
and that's a record in the history of
our country
unfortunately from the beginning our
opponents have shown themselves capable
of nothing but a partisan
ability to criticize when i took
bold action to issue a travel ban on
china
very early indeed joe biden called it
hysterical and xenophobic and then i
introduced a ban on europe very early
again
if we had listened to joe hundreds of
thousands more americans would have died
instead of following the science joe
biden wants to inflict a painful
shutdown
on the entire country his shutdown would
inflict
unthinkable and lasting harm on our
nation's children
families and citizens of all backgrounds
the cost of the biden shutdown would be
measured in increased drug overdoses
depression alcohol addiction suicides
heart attacks economic devastation
job loss and much more
joe biden's plan is not a solution to
the virus but rather it's a surrender
to the virus
alliteration my administration has a
very different approach
to save as many lives as possible we are
focusing on the science the facts and
the data
this is horrible we are aggressively
sheltering those at highest risk
especially the elderly allowing
lower risk americans to safely return
to work and to school and we want to see
so many of those great
states be open by democrats
we want them to be open they have to be
open they have to get back to work
they have to get back to work and they
have to get back to school
most importantly we are marshaling
america's scientific genius
to produce a vaccine in record time
under operation warp speed we have three
different vaccines in the final stage of
trials
right now years ahead of what has
been achieved before nobody thought it
could ever be done this fast normally it
would be years that we did it in a
matter of a few months
we're producing them in advance so that
hundreds of millions of doses will be
quickly available we will have a safe
and effective vaccine this year
and together we will crush the virus
might help not to have 1500 maskless
people sitting next to each other
word about their agenda but that's not
because they don't have one
it's because their agenda is the most
extreme set of proposals
ever put forward by a major party
nominee
joe biden may claim he is an ally of the
light
but when it comes to his agenda biden
wants to keep us
completely in the dark he doesn't have a
clue
he has pledged a four trillion dollar
tax hike
on almost all american families which
will totally collapse or rapidly
improving economy and once again
record stock markets that we have right
now
will also collapse that means your 401ks
that means all of the stocks
guys independently fact check me in
general
stock markets do better during
democratic presidents unemployment is
lower during democratic presidents
gdp growth is higher during democratic
presidents
and job creation is higher during
democratic presidents
consumer confidence index is higher
during democratic presidents just
i encourage everybody to go fact check
me america
and we will impose tariffs on any
company that leaves america
to produce jobs overseas
we will make sure our companies and jobs
stay in our country
as i've already been doing for quite
some time if you've noticed
joe biden's agenda is
made in china my agenda is
made in the usa
biden has promised to abolish the
production of american oil
coal shale and natural gas laying waste
to the
economies of pennsylvania ohio
texas north dakota oklahoma
colorado and new mexico destroying those
states
absolutely destroying those states and
others
millions of jobs will be lost and energy
prices will soar
these same policies led to crippling
power
outages in california just last week
everybody saw that tremendous power
outage nobody's seen anything like it
but
we saw that last week in california how
can joe biden claim to be an ally of the
light
when his own party can't even keep the
lights on
joe biden's campaign has even published
a 110-page
policy platform you can't get away from
this
co-authored with far left senator
crazy bernie sanders the biden bernie
manifesto calls for suspending all
removals
of illegal aliens implementing
nationwide catch and release
and providing illegal aliens with free
taxpayer-funded lawyers
everybody gets a lawyer come on over to
our country everybody has a lawyer we
have a lawyer for you that's what we
need is more lawyers
joe biden recently raised his hand
on the debate stage and promised to your
giveaway he was going to give it away
your health care dollars to illegal
immigrants which is going to bring
massive numbers of immigrants into
our country massive numbers will pour
into our country in order to get
all of the goodies that they want to
give education health care
everything he also supports deadly
sanctuary cities that protect criminal
aliens he promised to end national
by the way um it's absolutely insane
that
it's 11 10 on the east coast and this
shows no sign of slowing down i mean
it's
imagine if this goes to close to
midnight it's just delusional delusional
narcissistic the biden plan would
eliminate america's borders
in the middle of a global pandemic
and he's even talking about taking the
wall down how about that
biden also vowed to oppose school choice
and clothes
all charter schools ripping away the
ladder of opportunity for
black and hispanic children in a second
time joe biden's obviously not closing
all charter schools that's crazy to
every family in america
and we will always treat our teachers
with the tremendous
respect that they deserve
great people great great people
joe biden claims he has empathy
for the vulnerable yet the party he
leads supports the extreme late
term abortion of defenseless babies
right
up until the moment of birth
democrat leaders talk about moral
decency
but they have no problem with stopping a
baby's beating heart
remember we're supposed to believe
trump's against abortion now
democrat politicians refuse to protect
innocent life
and then they lecture us about morality
and saving america's
soul tonight we proudly declare
that all children born and unborn
have a god-given right to life
he glitched there
during the democrat convention the words
under god
were removed from the pledge of
allegiance
not once but twice we will never do that
but the fact is this is where they're
coming from
like it or not this is where they're
coming from
if the left gains power they will
demolish the suburbs
confiscate your guns there's that again
and appoint justices who will wipe away
your second amendment and other
constitutional freedoms
biden is a trojan horse for socialism if
joe biden doesn't have the strength
to stand up to there are millions of
people who wish that were true
but it's not true no radicals and there
are many
oh i just missed the word marxist too
sorry times incredible actually
then how is he ever going to stand up
for you
he's not the most dangerous aspect of
the biden platform
is the attack on public safety
the biden bernie manifesto calls for
abolishing cash bail
immediately releasing four hundred
thousand criminals onto the streets and
into your neighborhoods
when asked if he supports cutting police
funding
joe biden replied yes absolutely
when congresswoman ilhan omar
called the minneapolis police department
a
cancer that is rotten to the root biden
wouldn't disavow her support
and reject her endorsement he proudly
displayed it
shortly later on his website
displayed it in big letters make no
mistake
if you give power to joe biden the
radical left will defund
police departments all across america
they will pass federal legislation to
reduce law enforcement nationwide
they will make every city look like
democrat-run
portland oregon no one will be safe in
biden's america
my administration will always stand with
the men
and women of law enforcement
trump's face melting during deranged
diabolical speech
every day police officers risk their
lives to keep us safe
and every year many sacrificed their
lives
in the line of duty one of these
incredible americans was detective
miostas familia she was part of a team
of american heroes
called the nypd or new york's finest who
i was very very proud
to get their endorsement just the other
day
great people great great people
such politicians to do their job you'd
have no crime in new york
rudy giuliani knows that better than
anybody
thank you three years ago on the fourth
of july weekend
detective familia was on duty in her
vehicle when she was ambushed just after
midnight
and murdered by a monster who hated her
purely
for wearing the badge detective familia
was a single mom
she recently asked for the night shift
so she could spend more time with her
kids
two years ago i stood in front of the
u.s capitol alongside those beautiful
children
and held their grandmother's hand as
they mourned
their terrible loss and we honored
detective familia's extraordinary life
it was extraordinary
detective familia's three children
are with us this evening genesis peter
delilah
we are so grateful to have you here
tonight
thank you very much for coming thank you
very much
thank you very much
it's unreal i mean it is unreal
i promise you that we will treasure your
mom in our memories forever
we must remember that the overwhelming
majority of police officers in this
country
and that's the overwhelming majority
our noble courageous and honorable
we have to give law enforcement our
police
back their power
they are afraid to act
they are afraid to lose their pension
they are afraid to lose their jobs
and by being afraid they are not able to
do
the job that they so desperately want to
do for you
and those who suffer most are the great
people
who they protect and who they want to
protect
at an even higher level when there is
police misconduct the justice system
must hold wrongdoers fully and
completely accountable
and it will but when we can never
have a situation where things
are going on as they are today
we must never allow mob rule
we can never allow marlboro
in the strongest possible terms the
republican party condemns the rioting
looting arson and violence we have seen
in democrat-run cities all
like kenosha minneapolis portland
chicago and new york and many others
democrat run there is violence and
danger in the streets of many
democrat-run cities throughout america
this problem could easily be fixed
if they wanted to just call
we're ready to go in we'll take care of
your problem
in a matter of hours just call
we have to wait for the call it's too
bad we have to but we have to wait for
the call
we must always have law and order
all federal crimes are being
investigated prosecuted and punished to
the fullest extent of the law
when the anarchists started ripping down
our statues and monuments
right outside i signed an order
immediately
ten years in prison and it was a miracle
it all stopped
no more statues they said
that's just too long as they looked at a
statue i think we'll rip it down then
they said ten years in prison i think
that's too long
let's go home during their
convention joe biden and his supporters
remain completely silent about the
rioters and criminals
spreading mayhem in democrat-run cities
they never
even mentioned it during their entire
convention
never once mentioned now they're
starting to mention it
because their poll numbers are going
down like a rocking water
it's too late joe in the face of
left-wing anarchy and mayhem
in minneapolis chicago and other cities
joe biden's campaign did not condemn it
they donated to it at least 13 members
of joe biden's campaign staff donated
to a fund to bail out vandals arsonists
anarchists looters and rioters from jail
here tonight is the grieving family of
retired police captain
david dorn a 38-year veteran
of the saint louis police department a
great man and a
highly respected man by all in june
captain dorne was shot and killed as he
tried to protect the store
from rioters and looters or as the
democrats would call them
peaceful protesters starting to slur
they call them peaceful protesters
we're honored to be joined tonight
by his wonderful wife ann and beloved
family members brian
and kalyn to each of you we will never
forget the heroic
legacy of captain david dorn thank you
very much for being here
thank you
his i'm using a political prop voice is
so
distinct the tone when he's using a
political prop it's sick
as long as i am president we will defend
the absolute right of every american
citizen to live in security dignity and
peace
if the democrat party wants to stand
with anarchists
agitators rioters looters and flag
burners
that is up to them but i am starting to
repeat sections of the speech now
the republican party will remain the
voice of the patriotic heroes
who keep america safe and salute
the american flag
last year over 1 000 african americans
were murdered as a result of violent
crime in just four
democrat run cities
the top 10 most dangerous cities in the
country
are run by did he say 100 000 black
people were killed in four cities did i
mishear that
african americans are victims and
victims
of violent crimes in these communities
joe biden and the left ignore these
american
victims i never will if the radical left
takes power
they will apply their disastrous
policies to every city town
and suburb in america just imagine if
the so-called
peaceful demonstrators in the streets
were in charge of every lever
of power in the u.s government just
think of that
liberal politicians claim to be
concerned about the strength
of american institutions but who exactly
is attacking them who is hiring the
radical professors
judges and prosecutors who is trying to
abolish immigration enforcement
and establish speech codes designed to
muzzle
dissent in every case the attacks on
american institutions are being waged by
radical left he's still going always
remember they are
coming after me because i am fighting
for you
that's what's happening it's starting to
be castro-like to some degree i mean
it's not hours but we're getting to an
hour
or i even got elected
and remember this they spied
on my campaign and they
got caught obamacare now what happens
obamacare we must reclaim
our independence from the left's
repressive mandates
americans are exhausted trying to keep
up with the latest list of approved
words and phrases
and the ever more restrictive political
decrees
many things have a different name now
and the rules are constantly changing
the goal of cancel culture is to make
decent americans live in fear of being
fired
expelled shamed humiliated and driven
from society as we know
it the far left wants to coerce you into
saying
what you know to be false and scare you
out of saying
what you know to be true very sad
but on november 3rd you can send them a
very thundering message
they will never forget hopefully this is
the wrap-up
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
joe biden is weak
he takes his marching orders from
liberal
hypocrites who drive their cities into
the ground while fleeing far
from the scene of the wreckage these
same liberals want to eliminate
school choice while they enroll their
children in the finest private schools
in the land
they want to open our borders while
living in waldorf compounds and
communities
in the best neighborhoods in the world
they want to defund the police while
they have armed guards for themselves
this november we must turn the page
forever on this failed political class
the fact is i'm here
[Applause]
what's the name of that building
directly flouting the misuse of the
white house for a political event and
yes the word is flouting not flaunting
to me one of the most beautiful
buildings anywhere in the world and it's
not a building it's a home as far as i'm
concerned
not even a house it's a home it's a
wonderful place
with an incredible history but it's all
because of you
together we will write the next chapter
of the great american story
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
we will expand opportunity zones thank
you
baron respondent bring home
our medical supply chains and we will
end
our resilience for bad things
we will go right after china we will not
rely on them
one bit we are taking our business out
of china
we are bringing it home we want our
business
to come home we will continue to reduce
taxes and regulations at levels
not seen before we will create 10
million jobs
in the next 10 months and it will be
higher than that
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and surge federal prosecutors into
high crime communities we will ban
deadly sanctuary cities and ensure that
federal health care is protected
for american citizens not for illegal
aliens
we will have strong borders and i've
said for years without borders we don't
have a country
don't have a country strike down
terrorists who threaten our people
and keep america out of endless and
costly foreign wars
we will appoint prosecutors judges
justices
who believe in enforcing the law
not enforcing their own political
agenda
which is illegal we will ensure equal
justice for citizens of every race
religion color and creed we will uphold
your religious liberty and defend
your second amendment right to keep and
bear arms
melania not clapping for guns do you
guys notice that
interesting
and if we don't win your second
amendment doesn't have a chance
i can tell you that i have totally
protected it
we will protect medicare and social
security
we will always and very strongly protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
and that is a pledge from the entire
republican party thank you kevin
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency and further reduce
the cost of prescription drugs and
health insurance premiums they're coming
way down
we will greatly expand energy
development
continuing to remain the number one
in the world and keep america
energy independent
and for those of you that still drive a
car
look how low your gasoline bill is you
haven't seen that in a long time
we will win the race to 5g and build the
world's best
cyber and missile defense already under
construction
we will fully restore patriotic
education to our schools and
always protect that's weird we will
always always protect
free speech on college campuses
[Music]
and we put a very big penalty in
they do anything having to do with your
free speech
colleges have to pay a tremendous
tremendous financial penalty and again
it's amazing
how open they've been lately we will
launch
a new age of american ambition in space
america will land the first woman on the
moon
and the united states will be the first
nation to plant
its beautiful flag on mars
this is the unifying national agenda
that will bring our country together
so tonight i say to all americans this
is the
most important election i hope this is
the history of our country
there has never been such a difference
between two parties or two individuals
and ideology
philosophy or vision than there is right
now
our opponents believe that america is a
depraved nation
we want our sons and daughters to know
the truth
america is the greatest and most
exceptional nation
in the history of the world
our country wasn't built by cancer
culture
speech codes and soul-crushing
conformity
we are not a nation of timid spirits
we are a nation of fierce proud and
independent
american patriots we're a nation of
pilgrims pioneers adventurers explorers
and trailblazers who refuse to be tied
down held back
or in any way reigned in americans have
still in their spines grit in their
souls
and fire in their hearts there is no one
like us on earth i want every child in
america to know
that you are part of the most exciting
and incredible
adventure in human history
no matter where your family comes from
no matter your background in america
anyone can rise
with hard work devotion and drive you
can reach any goal
and achieve every ambition
our american ancestors sailed across
the perilous ocean to build a new life
on a new continent they braved the
freezing winters
crossed the raging rivers scaled the
rocky peaks
trekked the dangerous forests
and worked from dawn till dusk
these pioneers didn't have money they
didn't have fame
but they had each other they love their
families
they love their country and they loved
their god
when opportunity beckoned
they picked up their bibles packed up
their belongings
climbed into their covered wagons
and set out west for the next adventure
ranchers and miners cowboys and sheriffs
farmers and settlers they pressed on
past the mississippi
to stake a claim in the wild frontier
legends were born why erp
annie oakley davey crockett and buffalo
bill
americans built their beautiful
homesteads
on the open range soon they had churches
and communities
then towns and with time great centers
of industry and commerce
that is who they were
americans build their future we don't
tear down
our past we are the nation
that won a revolution
toppled tyranny and fascism
and delivered millions into freedom
we laid down the railroads built the
great ships
raised up the skyscrapers revolutionized
industry and sparked a new age of
scientific
discovery we set the trends in art and
music
radio and film sport and literature
and we did it all with style and
confidence and flair
because that is who we are
whenever our way of life was threatened
our heroes
answered the call from yorktown
to gettysburg from normandy to
iwo jima american patriots raced into
canon blasts bullets and bayonets to
rescue
american liberty they had no fear
but america didn't stop there
we looked into the sky and kept pressing
onward
we built a 6 million pound rocket and
launched it thousands of miles into
space
we did it so that two brave patriots
could stand tall and salute
our wondrous american flag planted on
the face of the moon
for america nothing is impossible
over the next four years we will prove
worthy of this
magnificent legacy we will reach
stunning new heights and we will show
that the world
for america there is a dream
and it is not beyond your reach
together we are unstoppable together we
are unbeatable
because together we are the proud
citizens
of the united states of america
painful and on november 3rd
we will make america
safer we will make america stronger
we will make america prouder
and we will make america greater than
ever before
i am very very proud to be
the nominee of the republican party
i love you all god bless you and god
bless america thank you
historically painful and humiliating
speech from donald trump
looking more orange than ever
i know we try to stay away from you know
melania's accent and this type of thing
but
whatever donald trump is doing to his
face i mean it looked like he was
melting
it looked like he was melting during the
speech and his words didn't make any
more sense either
just a bizarre meandering i think is the
way i would call it
painfully meandering speech
not even really justifying why we should
vote for him again essentially saying
things are terrible in huge parts of the
country give me another four years
but the things that are bad aren't my
fault but there'd be more of them if i
wasn't here
and i'll fix them if given another four
years even though i wasn't able to fix
them yet but everything's great
i don't know how else to sum it up
[Music]
yeah in a way the entire thing was sad
i don't know why sad is definitely an
adjective i would um
apply to it but i agree with you guys i
agree with you guys
[Music]
alright well listen guys we made it
through i'm going to sleep on this one
and then tomorrow
on the show i'll have a full breakdown
of the speech but
uh painful painful we made it that's
that's the uh the upside
we made it um through four days of this
insanity
i appreciate everybody who joined me
please do help me
you know the best way to thank me for
the programming if you think i deserve a
thanks
is if you're one of the 13 000 people
watching on youtube
hit that subscribe button help us get to
1 million subscribers before election
day
we could get to 9.75 right now if just a
fraction of you
hit that subscribe button same goes on
twitch make sure you're following me
trying to get to 50 000 followers there
we're going to be covering the debates
we're going to be covering
election day we're going to be covering
everything that's going on
between now and the election and um i do
invite you to hit that subscribe button
on youtube hit that follow button
on twitch i will see everybody tomorrow
you